all right and we are
live the last word with lord cognito
ibantis
and the greatest thai guy travis that we
know back on that friday morning
campfire a lot of things to discuss but
first let's start with the cheetah
how we doing e doing good getting ready
for vacation uh
some of you guys may know i will be gone
for the next two fridays
so i know cognito and travis will be
holding it down if anything big happens
um so stay tuned there follow them on
their twitters but i will be on vacation
so kind of prep and everything for that
i'm gonna have a master lost sector
for every day while i'm gone so i've got
them all recorded and prepped so
something at least while i'm up and gone
and then come back
i'll miss epilogue which we'll get into
here in a little bit but other than that
no just kind of
slowly working on prep and i've got like
two coved tests that i'm gonna have to
do when i leave and all this other stuff
going on so
made it through the whole all of this
without taking a test yet and then now
here they come so there they go no no
doubt no doubt
of course travis yes
i'm doing great man it's beautiful
morning here in san francisco we've got
halo infinite in the wild doing doing
those multiplayer bot sessions
we got uh fast nine available in home
theater this is just it's a great day
for everyone i think
no doubt and uh yeah i think we got like
a very
special guest here so i think we gotta
bring this man in right man indeed
so welcome to the last word number
160 always nice to get those round
numbers
and it's time to cross the proton pack
streams
cross-play details are here and we have
a great guest to discuss all things
destiny around the campfire this morning
we are joined today by a legend in the
destiny community whose roots are
planted deep
in nintendo land his desire to catch
them all has been around for a while and
still holds true
to this day if you look at his vault
halo is where he trained his fingers
or he trained his trigger fingers
climbing up quite high in the
competitive scene
but destiny is where he blended his rpg
upbringing with his shooter prowess
the campfire is honored to welcome a man
who may not be a fan of bows and destiny
but is very comfortable fiddling with
one in real life one who sees the
sandbox in nothing but cones
and is the controller pc player and who
has broken many on mouse and keyboard
hailing from the fifth largest city in
north america and buys all his yu-gi-oh
cards with canadian dollars
this crucible scientist fellow owner of
a full vault
and the one 420 69 sniper man
drewski how are you doing sir
wow i'm like overwhelmed by that intro
that was like
damn really uh really hyped me up there
geez
i'm doing a moment it's more it's
morning we gotta wake up do it right
we gotta wake you up yeah i mean that
was dude that was crazy
how you doing yeah i'm doing great i'm
uh i'm happy to be here to hang out and
talk and uh
just uh talk about the game and and
whatever else
well we definitely want to get to know
our guest a little bit so cog
what would you like to know about this
crucible map we we got to get into
before we get into all the great that's
detail we got to get into this gaming
history man i've seen some uh
some very cool titles obvious obviously
some standouts with pokemon and stuff
like that so like
game system wise you know i saw
obviously the nes stuff i've been
submitting and stuff
like was that kind of the first consoles
you kind of got into i just want to know
like
give me the origins of the game in
history
yeah i mean for me gaming started like
watching um
my cousins play on they had like an snes
and i i think it was like my uncle's
snes or something with super mario world
and that game was just like
wow to this day i think it's still so
addicting like i love that game
it's the whole time and then that like
evolved into like uh and then like
other cousins like hand-me-downs i
inherited like the game boy color with
pokemon silver and those were like
the very first games i played and that
slowly evolved into like the gamecube
uh where i love like uh i love like the
legend of zelda series there we had like
a promotional
pre-order disc for wind waker that had
like ocarina enough time on it majora's
mask
a bunch of like the n64 games which is
like really really cool um
yeah but we can't get them on switch
yeah i know it's just super it's like a
super reordered
promo desk i still have it yeah it's
it's really really
me too i have it as well nice nice nice
it's this really weird like
super rare it's actually super expensive
if you try to sell it or buy it online
but it has like oh really
all of the yeah it has like all the og
uh
uh zelda games and then it also has the
master quest
version of ocarina of time which is
pretty hard to get your hands on
actually unless you use an emulator so
uh yeah i have that disc too but yeah
that's like uh that's like that's how i
know you're og when it comes to nintendo
if you got one of those
hold
but that's where i started like loving
zelda and like all those kind of games
like
stemmed from like that era and i only
started i wasn't allowed to play
first person shooter games for a long
time i remember going to like middle
middle school and like i was like
canadian like halo was like the stuff
yeah well my um like a long time ago my
my like my mom did work for like uh
applying like ratings to things so it
was like yeah i wasn't allowed to play
it because it's rated mature
or it's like gsrb style your mom's a
narc
and it was like yeah so like for halo it
was like the only exception because i
had to like
write a like almost like a paper
explaining why it was like sci-fi
and stuff like that it was crazy because
in school i had to listen to my friends
every day like everyone's like talking
about halo 2 halo 3
comparing their like bungie profiles i
was like man this
sucks and i want to play so badly and
then i was
finally allowed to and i like went super
hard and
i got destroyed by all my friends it was
like it was so bad like someone got out
beard by me it was like
it was like the utmost embarrassment for
them i was so terrible
but i think because of that i wanted to
get really really good
and show them like yeah i can be good
and that's like and then it's history
from there
with fps nice so you had to you had to
prove to mom why yeah
yeah it's like it's sci-fi it's like
star wars you know like
nice i love it it's fine it's fine it's
just star wars it's good
stars good that's what's up oh real
quick before i pass it over
um zelda witch since you're the other
guy which
which is like your favorite zelda was
like you're iconic man
yeah that's such a hard one picking
children over here
yeah you gotta rake your kids i feel
like the safe answer for me here
is ocarina of time but that's like such
a like
typical answer if i had to go with like
a little bit more of a
risky answer i guess twilight princess
okay
okay interesting okay okay
i respect it i respect it had that i
disagree on twilight princess
i understand i understand because i also
want to say ocarina but it's just so
basic
yeah there's something that it did
though like because i played the
eight-bit zelda one i went through
played that had enough rupees got the
dumb blue ring i remember that stupid
grind when i was a kid
and all of a sudden it's like it goes
you see mario do
the mario world but it's still mario and
then all of a sudden you're in this like
hack and slash
3d adventure in ocarina and something
about that switch that always still like
sits in my mind it's like it's hard not
to vote it near the top of
the importance of the game for me so i'm
with you
i mean like a lot of my controversial
picks for things i like to justify
really because i i love
the music and twilight princess uh it
was like zelda for me was always about
the music
i played violin from a young age and a
big reason was uh
was because of legend of zelda and like
hearing the strings and
um the music and then like i i loved uh
twilight princess music
especially so we need to get you a
collaboration controversial choice
with my usual music trump card so yeah
salute no doubt no doubt trash what you
got for drewski
yeah diving into first person shooter
since you said that you were rubbish at
halo
i'm wondering what was the first shooter
where you sort of turned the corner
and felt like you were um a tryhard
because i know you're a tryhard and
crucible trust me um so
what what what kind of what kind of got
you into that competitive spirit
hmm i i think the tale like the ver so
when i started playing i was like super
like
i loved just party game modes and
infection and the custom games
halo had and it was like all about the
social thing like hanging out with
friends
and my friends used to like put me into
mlg matches
where they would stack the teams and
have like their team versus like me and
like
three other like i don't know people
that just knew online that were like
clearly worse
and they would spawn kill me for like
like half an hour at a time
and so my relation early to what mlg was
i didn't even know what it was i was
just like this is the gamer that they
put me in to like
destroy me for half an hour so i was
like i hate this
and until one day where i like finally
like
looked at it and i was like wow this is
like a sport like this is like
really cool like there's teams and they
they they treat it like like a sport and
like that was so fascinating to me that
people were like
playing in tournaments and winning money
and like um i i love
soccer or football growing up so they i
related it to like that but i was i was
like pretty bad up until
my i think in the moment i want to say
halo reach
maybe nearing the end of halo reach i
started to feel competent
um in the moment i felt that way but in
retrospect i really want to say halo 5s
when i got decent
um i don't know i i felt like
i think i went through a thing where
like i think a lot of kids do
uh and this is why i kind of have
empathy for it where i had a nice big
ego at one point
and it's just like you know thought i
was a lot better than i was
she was she was hot yeah you know
exactly like i was like well like you
know between like 15 and 17 years old
and like playing those games and
finally started getting good and yeah i
beat all the friends in my neighborhood
everyone
yeah you know what i mean like and it's
just like so
in the moment i want to say reach is
where i started getting competent but
the truth is
reaches when i really started to like
kind of like understand
like the the bare minimum of like how to
play competitively and then maybe i want
to say like halo
5 is where i actually could be more
comfortable in saying like yeah i was i
was
i was good at it modest that was good
just clicking heads over here i feel you
definitely feel you with uh thinking
that you're the best pvp player in the
world 15 to 17. i think if you
uh if you ask like the typical 15 to 17
year old pvp
player if they know the greatest player
of all time though
you'll get that uh obi-wan kenobi
response well of course i know him
that's just like the typical and that's
your one star wars reference for the day
like obviously you enjoyed zelda kind of
the action adventure stuff you had
shooting
and a little bit of the rpg how did you
get into
trading cards like yu-gi-oh is something
i've heard you talk about
forever like any time i've heard you
anywhere i swear it pops up
it's like travis in a star wars are fast
and furious like he's always got one a
show i feel like i've heard you talking
about a lot
how how did you get into that and like
how deep did that rabbit hole actually
go
um it was really funny because it was
just something that me and my cousins
had in common
and we all like really enjoyed and like
our oldest cousin like
got me into it when i was like really
young um
so like we always enjoyed it from then
and i enjoyed collecting the cards when
i was a kid as many other i think kids
and like my age group did um but it was
it was something that we started doing
again because
me and my cousins wanted to find
something to like
have an excuse to do to spend time um
and what we really
stumbled upon was like this really
awesome
scene in toronto of like both really
cool people but like
really competitive people and those
those guys are some of my best friends
now and
like there's the people i hang out on
discord with and like chill with and
some of these guys have like gone to
worlds and like
oh wow some of them a few times it's
like they're they're insanely good but
um
having that mix of like just an irl
like fun hobby competitive thing
that also has like some really great
people i enjoy spending time with in
this community that i
uncovered really like ramped up my
passion for the game i still play like
semi-casual competitively like a healthy
medium there but
um the community was really great and it
was also at a time in my life where
um i was doing nothing but like
playing video games and making youtube
videos and had like very little like
face-to-face social interaction
and um i didn't realize how much that
mattered in the moment but like oh yeah
yeah there's something about obviously
being in the presence
um of someone else and like you know
like seeing the look in their eye and
like that
that interaction and like going outside
and that that's so good for your mental
health i think and that was part of that
so that's why i'm very fond of that game
in general
i agree it's funny you said it because
um i know addict he's
you know he's huge in the yu-gi-oh
and he would tell me the stories in the
competitive scene oh addicted lord
addict is over he's a beast like he
he would go hard or he would tell me
like he was in tournaments they would
fly
all over the place and yeah addict right
you wouldn't think him
i i didn't see it same thing and he told
me the yu-gi-oh stories and i was just
like
blown away so to hear drewski talk about
it it's like i completely understand
where he's coming from and then
he made a fantastic point obviously
about you know the in-person competition
because
i'm the older gent on the on the cast
here
yeah i'm the old statesman here so you
know look
it's important i think that you know
like you said you know being able to see
your opponent
also i mean i don't know how you give it
i'm assuming it's not is there trash
talking to you
let me just ask that first before you
know it for sure
[Music]
if there is it's like super super light
because it's a
they they take that stuff pretty
seriously i think it's all like
moderated or like there's like judges
like yellow cards okay
you got a game loss so like it's you
know it's
see i always hope i was hoping that like
uh you know when stuff got real
we got to see like kami drewski come out
you know like you got a deeper voice and
eyeliner or something like that or i
changed his personalities
for people who actually know yu-gi-oh
but there you go
it's actually spiky
exactly he's like a foot taller somehow
nobody notices
uh i i i knew nothing about you
my entire life and then like last year
during covet one of the things i did
with my time is i was like
i'm gonna get to the bottom of what the
heck is going on in yu-gi-oh and i
watched the entire show and i was like
wow
this is nonsense and i i so now i know
way too much about the yu-gi-oh show
that's so funny no it's cool i mean like
i said like you were saying before it's
just like
you know that that physical that human
interaction and competitiveness and the
tension of it knowing that there's a
person there you're going
it's different and it's good for mental
health i think it's good for
you know of competition in person versus
just the online thing where it's like a
you know faceless entity kind of thing
so
salute to you that's why we need our gcx
time
can't get here soon enough yeah i know i
know hopes uh
some of the bounds might be for me so
we'll talk about that off live but um
yeah the only thing i was gonna say
quick before i get uh given travis was
just um
you know obviously this game destiny and
stuff like that but prior to that
you know you mentioned halo fighting for
that that you know in the house to play
it
and then you're getting into it so was
it
halo was your transition to destiny or
like destiny was still separate i just
want to know like what because i know
some people have halo as the backbone
that transitions them into destiny and
then some people are like
i've never played halo and you know or
whatever you know guys so i'm just
curious that relationship with halo and
destiny with you
yeah i mean i think halo is the game i
spend so much time in because like i
said i was so inspired by the thought of
like
this is a sport it's it behaves or
people treat it like
a sport there's teams and like again
that always just like hit home for me
and like the
i always chase it was always about
chasing that dream of
wanting to you know be a professional
player like compete at that level and
you know
however that feels so halo is definitely
the backbone for me i got into destiny
because um destiny came out in this
period of time where like
uh i think the master chief collection
was like not out yet
for and like destiny was out for a month
before so i didn't actually know
anything about destiny
um i went in completely blind uh i
didn't know a thing about it
i didn't know what to expect i played
the beta maybe which was like
fun it felt good um but not too much
so going into it i had no expectations i
didn't know anything
honestly at that point coming off of
halo reach i didn't have high hopes for
a bungee game because
halo reach wasn't the most i don't know
uh beloved halo in terms of i think
competitive standpoint
oh yeah maybe from a pvp standpoint yeah
i would just yeah
exactly so like i was like you guys came
for you just then but
the pvp guys they definitely agree yeah
even the custom game options like it was
like super fun the game was like awesome
and but like to me i think for the
competitive portion specifically it
wasn't
phenomenal um but uh
so anyways that like because of all
those reasons i had like literally zero
expectations for destiny
and i ended up playing it and getting
really into it and what i think
really set me um over the top was like
the fact that i had like this pvp
experience that
felt familiar-ish but unique in its own
way
but on top of that that whole like uh
mmo quote unquote
aspect i know that we only recently
started cleaning this
shout out to luke yeah you know
like that like vault of glass was just
something that felt
so grand to me it was like this
accumulation of like so many
things i loved about games it's like
there's this fun competitive pvp aspect
that feels like this hybrid of maybe
like
cod and halo but unique in its own way
it's got these
really cool weapons that have like these
beautiful neat
aesthetics to them that feel like give
them a personality and
and the aesthetics match the function
and then there's like these
this raids that feel like something out
of like what was the most relatable
thing to me at the time was like legend
of zelda right which like so i loved all
these things
and it kind of came together in one
place and like that made me really love
the game
of course like after a master chief
collection came out unfortunately the
launch of that game was incredibly rough
so like i just kept playing destiny um i
did go to a tournament for that game
soon after uh but like after that i
didn't
play it much again um because of like
how like rough
the uh the launch was
um oh and yeah and that kind of like
helped me stick with destiny uh
also i think that's like when i i just
randomly uploaded a video because i got
a new capture card it was like no sound
or anything
just like hey this is where you get the
pre-order bonus it's literally just a
minute of me walking up and like
grabbing the pre-order bonus and i got
like a few hundred k views or something
like that and i was like
whoa i was like that's like that's neat
right i was like whoa
like that's a that's kind of neat so
maybe i'll play this game more
everything's pointing to it so yeah nice
i
see it she read this man for past drafts
yeah it's funny you
i love the way you describe destiny
because
i think that's the first time someone
verbalized
exactly why i fell in love with it and
it was
i felt like i was getting away with
something like
i i was cheating i was getting like
three four games in one
right i was getting this pvp component
and at first i remember didn't like i
was just like i thought pvp was weird
travis like
i thought it was like i was like why
they have this opera voiced guy
talking like i didn't understand what
was going on driver now
yeah now i love you know what man what's
my man from the walking dead
yeah i remember being weirded out i was
like what is this right and then
you get into it i'm like all right like
like drewski said it felt familiar
though because you know you came from
halo you can't
you know that part then you did you had
a campaign you had a pv and then like
you said with the weapons with this
the i remember reading like flavor text
and it was like what is this
and exotics and you you're like yo this
is really cool
you know kind of thing and then
obviously the way you described the raid
was literally how i felt it was just
like
you know is this a dungeon it was just
this whole unique thing and
and i've never played like an mma or a
cooperative type of game like that
so yeah great description i i felt like
all these different
worlds into one package so i just
wouldn't get bored but enough bloating
for me
try what you got for a man because we go
we get into that all day
yeah no i i think that's interesting
that you bring up like the
uniqueness of the feel of pvp and
destiny because
it sort of has a uh a really unique role
in like the lexicon of
of uh of like multiplayer games because
we were used to
in bungee games having a narrator who
said like oh you got a double kill and
that sort of stuff
but we weren't used to like this guy
talking over who was like
in canon in the universe and almost like
giving you bits of
narrative in the pvp and it was sort of
jarring at first and
now it's like almost natural because you
have like games like overwatch and
pvp only games where like the whole
point is that you're getting narrative
while you do
uh pvp but that was sort of a new
element a new aspect
to uh to i think the fps world when when
destiny did it so
uh yeah i think i i totally remember
that i think it was during the beta
jax was like shouting things at me and i
was like who the hell is this guy this
is such a weird
like what's going on right now but but
you liked it and you grew to like him
over time and that's funny you know
you almost you almost never interact
with shacks outside of crucible but you
feel close to him because he's always in
your ear right and
i think there's a certain there's a
certain power to be able to to do that
over time
yeah so you mentioned uh the raid as
being the reason
that you kind of like stuck with destiny
and it was the reason that you
you uh the light bulb kind of went off
and i think that's true of a lot of us
here it's certainly true for me
i reviewed the original destiny and gave
it a six out of ten but when that
vaulted glass came out it was like all
right this is a different game now like
something has really changed um
so i i definitely appreciate that when
was the moment
you realized that the pvp
connected with you for destiny because i
know a lot of people
especially people who are used to halo's
very high bar for comp
kind of look at destiny as you know it's
not really built for a comp it has
hundreds of weapons it's never been
balanced in any iteration of its sandbox
uh so so when did you sort of start to
align more with the pvp side of things
and and why
um that's that's a tough question
because uh like you said like i think a
lot of people like look at destiny it's
like not
that competitive game um and i
like i don't think i ever thought of it
like that for a long time i always
thought it was just like this like for
fun game where i want to use things that
like
look cool to me be and like do well with
them because they
look cool or feel cool and again it was
like this
i felt like it's it scratched this weird
itch
of like being not quite halo but not
quite call of duty it was like this
kind of cool mix that incorporated its
own
aspect with the abilities into it and it
felt really awesome like i always loved
the blade dancer like that was my
favorite class and i played it all
through destiny one
um so like that class just felt so
awesome
that uh that kind of fantasy that it had
to it and and then like it was like
again the accumulation of like the
fantasy the functionality of the sandbox
whether you're using something because
it looks cool or it's effective so but i
it was for fun for a long time i only
started taking the game
um quote-unquote more seriously it was
like
towards the very very tail end and it
wasn't even
i don't want to even say like in a great
place at that point
um in destiny 1 so i want to say that i
really really
really took it seriously in a destiny 2
beta interesting interesting because it
felt more like
halo to me even during
uh trials debut house of wolves time
yeah i mean a lot of people you know
usually like regard that as like the
the mecca i guess of destiny 1 pvp i
i actually um i stopped playing for a
long time
got it right after that came out um
and like i just wasn't playing video
games a lot to be honest uh
i i i wasn't like i played occasionally
it's not that i
didn't like it but i wasn't sold on it i
guess i don't know i liked vanilla like
i liked d1 vanilla a lot like
if i had to compare like my favorite
times in destiny was like d1 vanilla
i liked uh d201
and then i think i liked um forsaken
okay those are like my three favorite
times where i was like really in love
with the pvp so i i don't know like
i know a lot of people love that time
maybe i wasn't into it enough but okay
it was never like just a memorable time
for me
enough e yeah i was like before we go
too far into destiny because i want to
transition with one piece when you talk
about this like
month of chaos for you but taking away
from that i did want to take a second uh
collaboration between you and lindsay
sterling win
[Laughter]
that's a i love lindsay sterling she's
super cool i actually i actually met her
once really
um yeah so this was like when she was
like really small
um like not nearly as big i guess on
youtube uh i went to one of her concerts
and uh
she was like she came out back
afterwards and like see like hi everyone
type thing and
sign something for me it was like super
cool and i got a picture and the picture
was taken by my friend
and it was really blurry and i didn't
see what's after and i was like uh
i'd be so dude you gotta have that
trusty person on the camera man that's
oh
that's right lesson learned yeah i love
love since earlier
like stuff like that was like always
super inspiring to me when i would like
struggle to find appreciation in my
in the violin yeah because you said
you've done violin and piano for
a while off and on but you said you're
kind of getting back into it more
seriously
now or more recently at least yeah yeah
i haven't played violin in a while i'm
probably quite rusty
i plan to hopefully uh go back and take
lessons soon enough but i recently got
myself a new piano and i've been playing
that and practicing very very hard
music is something that is uh near and
dear to me
and uh i've i've played for a decent
amount of time
but like i really really want to like
make it something serious and
committed to being a part of my life so
nice no doubt
good to have a little culture with our
gaming yes yes yes gotta have culture
also explains the love of bungie games
always
oh yeah oh excellent
what was the zelda 25 the orchestral one
that they did too
i love that yeah yeah i love that so
much great so like
listening into my car like a big giant
nerd driving around me like look at me
and i'm like
got like orchestra music in the car and
it's all zelda and i'm just and i'm just
like loving every minute of it i'm like
i don't even care what you're seeing in
here i'm
i'm having a blast no zelda's music is
in college it's beautiful yeah yeah
zelda's music was pretty iconic but yeah
as we kind of transition into destiny
the one thing i wanted to ask about you
said you've got
quite a story about you said the kind of
your top moment in the franchise before
we get into the recent events
kind of right around forsaken something
something was going on with you so
so what was what what happened there
what's what's what happened around
forsaken that seems to be a big one for
you
yeah so i mean i think that's the time
where i started to
i i think that i had both a good amount
of personal growth in that time
um but also like that's where my
i feel like my content started to like
really uh
become like a little bit more solid or i
was like getting
getting a little bit of traction um so
it was both again personal growth and
and traction behind my content but
something that me and uh
me and cam i guess the story starts here
we always tell the story this is like
our like
i don't know bar story we joke about uh
me and cammy cakes
we joked about when we saw the lunas
howl originally
in that what was it forsaken pvp preview
or something
um we you know everyone noticed or some
people noticed that it was like yo that
was a 180 hand cannon like a three tap
right which was like crazy and um i
think like as more details came out like
they realized that was going to be the
the pinnacle weapon uh
because that was the second after
redrix's um so yeah that was gonna be
the pinnacle weapon and we were like yo
what if
we got that and
we also like you know jokingly you know
starting our buyer
by borrow high here like got world's
first and last wish and like
took our lunas house into last wish and
like just
completely as we say for lack of a
better tournament [ __ ] bucket
and like you know just like go no
absolutely no life and do it and we
joked about it
but we were like half serious about it
so like
um that month leading up to uh uh
forsaken we we were playing a lot
um uh we we gamed a lot uh as well and
like uh
gamed a lot with a lot of friends and
got a lot of redrix claim wars and
helped people get regis claim wars and
it was just such a
such a fun time where it felt like uh i
was both growing
or i felt i grew or was growing as a
person but also like gameplay wise and
we had this great group of friends so it
was just a lot of really memorable
moments going for the rhetorics but then
after forsaken came out
um or sorry i'm trying to organize here
before
forsaken came out there was like that
one week period
yes where the weapon system switched
but the new weapons weren't out and
that's actually like
was a super super fun time i thought it
was incredibly well
balanced because we didn't get hit with
some of the power creep
which followed forsaken
so i remember that that stuck out of me
okay so timeline here forsaken releases
we were going for um
we were going for obviously you're gonna
we were gonna raid for the last question
go for worlds first
no that was that was the dream and um we
did end up like going and getting like
not going to level but first things
first go get luna's hell
uh at the time was just like a nightmare
it was like man you were waiting like
hours for a match like
we did things like i'm not gonna lie
like we stayed so in survival
if you get to know lives remaining and
if
you killed someone and then killed
yourself like a second later it would
tithe around
so we had to get solar kills so like
we're like we're gonna have to wait an
hour for a game so let's just keep this
one going as long as we can
yeah you're gonna do it wow
yeah it was like there was some crazy
stuff but anyways like we we ended up
like doing some crazy things together
lunas
uh and then we finally did and that
quest it was like it was
easier to get the points than it was to
get the quest done because you couldn't
get games to get all the kills you
needed
right um so anyways we got that and then
we like
saw there was another step in the like
oh well what it what is this
and then that's when the not forgotten
got discovered and we were like well we
have to do this too
right and we're like looking at each
other like right
and then yeah so we ended up doing it
and then
i remember we ended up having only three
days
two or three days to level something
ridiculous and it's like dude we got
like a bunch of friends like rally us
through we were up for like
i don't know i think we were getting
like three hours of sleep per day
to make sure that we were leveled for
the raid because we told our friends
like we
rest assured like we will be ready like
you don't got to worry
we will be ready and and we're going to
get these guns
um and yeah we were like up around the
clock and it got so close to the point
where like
if we so i don't know if you guys
remember when you're leveling through
forsaken there was like one
public event that was like bugged or
something where like if you missed it
you could potentially wait like an
hour to like get it again and like we
like we're like we were there like a
minute to spare like
leveling through the campaign getting to
that point it was like crazy how fast
we had to be and it was just hilarious
to look back at
and we we hit everything we needed to we
literally got
three hours of sleep before the raid
woke up like
minutes on time and then like did the
raid and we didn't know how long
last week was gonna be oh yeah that was
already we all know how
long last wish was 24 hours in about two
minutes
oh yeah that world first seriously
exactly
said we were up for 24 hours
oh my gosh after that three hours yeah
it was it was disgusting i don't know
how i did it i will never know how i did
that or cam did
that together with me that was gross
um but it was super memorable and funny
because we ended up getting
i think like sixth place or something oh
wow congrats something
yeah it was just something much better
than we ever assumed with this stupid
gag or like stupid meme that we were
like joking about
uh and it was funny because i think like
one of the engagements
i think it was a shirochi um
where yeah we were about to wipe and
like cam was like the last one alive
and he was at a special and he was just
like using not not forgotten much at the
time did
massive damage yeah because like he hit
the two headshots proc magnificent hell
and it would just
keep trucking with each shot and we
cleared it for that reason we're like
yes
wow yes they're not forgotten we did it
it was just so stupid
yeah exactly exactly like it was so so
stupid
but like looking back it was some of the
best memories i had with like my group
of friends and
with cami and stuff it was hilarious
nice i remember that that was that was a
tough that was the time the grind the
the i forgot the pinnacle and the fact
that you guys are using the raid i think
it's just hilarious but um yeah oh it
was so funny
but yeah i mean like in the discovery
aspect like every that unknown with like
the dreaming city and everything
learning about everything and even the
unknown and like not forgotten oh it was
just
what a time what a release no doubt
really sad we are
quote never getting one of those
forsaken style expansions again
correct is that that one yeah
it did definitely definitely
been there now i forgot definitely top
tier video oh you got a super chat there
uh
jeff i know that's not that's right yeah
forte in here
love the power squad of cognito thai guy
and ivan just glad to see our cones
are all in a line happy to see you on
youtube while i struggle working yeah
we're keeping people
awake this morning and we apparently are
keeping drewski awake as well just got
to get them hyped with these stories
halo talk
just gotta mention yu-gi-oh
one more question i did want to ask how
do you feel being the infamous creator
of the um
stasis breaking shadow dive sir
yeah talk about it man i'm cool with it
i love it
whenever like someone's like like oh
you're the person that
started this whether i did or not i know
like i know it's like not the most
uh i don't know some people have a
problem with that but anyways whether i
did or not like
some people like brand me as the poster
boy of it i guess i'm like totally fine
with it man because like i'm someone
that like
it to me the way i always saw that was
like i loved it because it was
i saw i hate shotguns i use shotgun
sometimes but i i really dislike them
i'm coming the same way yeah and to me
it was a stupid solution to a stupid
problem that's how i always felt about
it so i'm like
okay like get to enjoy shotgun i get to
enjoy haha
you know and it was just it was
something amusing to me because
um something uh the initial drop of it
don't get me wrong was like
way too powerful it was like it was like
way too strong
definitely um but the the thought behind
it was always entertaining to me
because even when it was absolute meta
and even now when i see
a revenant um people like
wouldn't respect it if that makes sense
so i make that comparison to yu-gi-oh
where like there's things that
you know exist in the game and you have
to respect it
so like you have to play around it
mentally whether you know they have it
for sure or not
because like if not you could like lose
the game so that was like one of those
things where i'm like
okay you know i'm playing revenant you
know and you
actively complain that i do this why are
you flying at me and rushing at me
instead of playing an angle while you
have me weak with your primary
because like at then at that point i
always felt like it's it's
that you played into it you could have
played it
yeah and that that was like that kind of
thought was always amusing to me because
like i'd always see like them like they
just keep
not playing around it but want to keep
like complaining about it complain about
it so that justifies it but like
change the way you like you know change
around it try and respect it yeah
yep yeah good point good good good
engagement involved
yeah with you there people people who
complain about exploits and games
they're
not built for pvp also known as hunters
oh the whiners yeah
okay i mean like i i think that it's
important to say that
you are allowed to have discontent with
the meta game right like
oh for sure especially
yeah and like not nothing i say about
like you know you
like play around it like justifies the
state of it or the potency of it for
sure but like if you're gonna choose to
play the game you might as well
do that i think you might as well like
play
around how the game is currently playing
i'm so glad you said that
because um i have an internal fight with
uh some clan mates
i gotta call him out he's not in the
chat right now but uh my boy sinista i
love him i love sinister
but sinister is a whiny and complainy
meta
hunter he got no disruptive hunters but
it's just that my thing is that destiny
goes through these
these cyclical metas where you know
something is just ridiculously
strong right something is just
ridiculously the more
effective thing to do right and yes
getting killed by it rapidly does get
annoying sometimes i'm not going to say
it doesn't
but at some point you make the perfect
point whiskey like if you're choosing to
continue to play this game consistently
you better adapt or change the way you
engage
you know what i'm saying to the whole
situation so that
is where i'm at with it and it's just
like so the people who continue to play
and steal wine wine wine wine what's
going on i'm like
nah you don't say i can't can't okay
i can't cos that yeah and i mean like i
think it's
again just to like empathize and try and
put myself into the player's shoes it's
like i get it
sometimes it's like hard to just like
it's easier said than done to just like
quote-unquote not play right
if you're really having uh that little
fun but i have like a few like kind of
like
kind of trains or schools of thought for
myself when i
fall into those categories it's like a
it's either you
accept the meta use the meta or find
something better than it and like play
around it
b don't play like you said or c i mean
sometimes for me there are things that i
find so unfun and like
that are the winning strategies that i
just accept like i'm not willing to do
that
and it compromises my fun too much so i
just don't think anything of losing to
it i'm like okay they are using the
better thing
i'm gonna choose to use whatever
anti-meta or
off meta strategy i'm going to because i
find more enjoyment out of it
maybe it's something that i feel
directly counters that i don't know
but to me it's just like if i if i win
great i'm going to do my best to win and
like and be successful but if i lose
it's just about just not putting weight
into it and be like okay like that was
the better thing i almost have
expect to lose right so that's that's
how i try and temper myself
yeah yeah i i totally agree for me it's
not like hey
if you don't like the meta stop playing
it's hey if if you
uh if the meta changes don't expect like
oh
why why is the strata the only strategy
i ever employed not working in the new
meta it's like you have to adapt to the
way
that the game is now being played right
like if you like to just
run and rush people shotguns and now
there's this perfect counter to it then
maybe the strategy of running and
rushing with shotguns
is not something you should be doing
anymore
and if that isn't fun for you then you
know you can get out of pvp or you can
just accept the fact that
sometimes when you rush with shotguns
you're going to get countered by this
thing that is
seems designed to counter that so it's
just you know you have to
you have to be willing to play within
the boundaries of the new meta even when
it's unfair and in destiny
in my professional opinion is almost
always
in a in a uh in a imbalanced state and
that's
you kind of have to accept that when you
play this game if you want a balanced
game
there are a lot of other pvp games that
work really hard to just give you
a balanced experience but destiny is not
one of them it's got way too much going
on in it it's
sandboxes is very complicated and a
jungle and
uh you're just not going to get balance
and to me that's part of the fun
part of the fun is that it's rarely
balanced and it is
exciting and constantly changing and uh
you know
when i want a arena experience i'll just
boot a payload but
if i want something that's uh a little
more uh off the wall then then destiny
definitely fits that bill so oh pardon
the interruption we we have a fraudulent
ninja
in the chat so you can do the artists or
i i'm flattered i'm flattered that
someone likes to run around with my like
this but that is not me
so who is that that lord incognito in
here that is not the real ninja he's
he's a fan and it's cool respect no hate
but
can't be in here impersonating people
thank you sir
you wanna gone yes please bye
into the shadow realm sir i'm sorry you
have to get your whole night into your
feet
and be yourself all right you can you
can come back as you
just not me that's well i asked
i didn't know if that was a joke from my
album
other people from other channels have
told me that uh yeah spend
another cog running around asking for
bot status that's what you know
yeah no i knew that so i literally make
me a body and i'll get the fake out
no i saw it i was good though that was
good that was good no i just turned i'll
be back
into a mod so it's fine what takes
laughing
it was kind of funny he was like yeah e
we gotta get him out of here
he's gotta get me that iron lords
podcast out of here yeah who is that
this is what happens when we go to
youtube just you know everything goes
off the rail you guys don't know what
you hey cocky you got to respect him for
living up to that ninja
assassin
doppelgangers and all that respect
respect though
you can come back just be yourself
that's all well
uh truly it is awesome to get to know
you we got uh some cool information
that's hopefully gonna change the game
coming up a little bit
um so cross play that's the big one
that was the giant piece of the twab so
we got a lot to talk about on this one
i'm going to kind of go through the
pieces that
need to wait are we going to pass the
interview section
no not if we not if you don't want to be
we can we got you got something
i'm just we haven't gotten to my
favorite part of all of our pvp
interviews
you know our our long running uh
our long long no
stop trying to make trout stop trying to
make uh fetch happen seriously
is this a segment in time oh yes no we
have a we have a long running segment
here at uh
last
i'd weekend holding up a different
figure if this wasn't on youtube
and it's called let's help ebantus
it's one of my favorite segments it's a
segment where we ask
we ask uh pvp mains
to come onto the show and give their top
tips for crucible so that
our friend ibontis can spend less time
in the shadow realm
so if you have any tips uh
drewski now would be your time just for
people out there who are aspiring to get
better pvp
and not have 0.43 kd uh like like
ibontis over here
um what would you recommend to them
hmm i i think it's a it's it's super
it's super super broad and you can talk
about so many things but uh
the two things that really stick out in
my head the first one is like always
uh review your gameplay uh look back at
it record it if you want or stream if
you have to keep a vlog or something
uh look back over it and and identify
like where you did things that you
believe is like good
and where you could have done something
different and like take note of that
um and also like watching other great
players and noticing what they do
and not only that but asking yourself
why are they doing those things and you
know
i think a film review is just such a
important part of improving
i know any time that i've made like
significant strides i feel in my play
it's like usually been because of like
film and vod reviews something i still
do with my friends
um and i think they still do that and
they do that in professional sports
everything so i think that's a huge one
secondly i think mental mental game is
is so
so huge and i think it doesn't matter
what skill level or bracket or whatever
you want to put yourself at
i think your mental game and your mental
uh is so so important it's something
that i struggle with and i think i still
struggle with and
feeling inconsistent in that uh and i
guess
how to improve that or how to you know
be
better at having a good mental uh is not
dwelling perhaps on actions and not
being overly attached to outcomes i
think a lot of players get like really
in myself included get really
really upset when they see something
happen or you know
something to go a certain way how do you
feel when you guys hit you
oh i hate bose and i hate noob tubes
yeah it's just like don't don't be
attached i i find that i get
in my lowest lows when i'm you know when
i when i have a when i'm really attached
to things i think um
uh what's his name uh savage or kenny
uh vicaro um he owns g1 something that
he said that stuck out at me and
always stick out of me is that when
you're an athlete you gotta have a
short-term memory
you know you make a great play doesn't
matter you move on that was in the play
you make a bad play you're not dwelling
on it it's just you're always thinking
what's the next play what's
what's the next thing uh and i think
that's uh
that was like something that stuck with
me and i'm still trying to improve on
that i'm not a lead at it so
lots of improvements to make but i think
that that whole mentality thing is
is really important more important than
i think people think
great great advice got a couple of great
tips from chat too can i have to throw a
few of these out there uh chibi kim's
got some
some good ones uh if you're a hunter
wear stompies
if you're a warlock wear geomags titans
just punch stuff so she's got all the
classes covered
yep griff has got run away from the red
blips on the radar
and final one outsanity if you're bad at
pvp give your account to your sweat lord
friend
[Laughter]
these all seem like very bad tips but
hopefully your jerusalem will too yes no
those are good it's good to get out of
your head especially
but as you said the short-term memory is
a good thing if you really wanted that
one kill thought you had it then you
don't get it don't be down on yourself
just move on to the next thing yeah you
can't dwell
absolutely right especially you know
competitive pvp trials
sometimes like i think your mindset is
so important because like if you
if you're losing a couple of rounds a
couple of matches and you get down or
you get too
angry and too overly sensitive with
stuff that can affect you
and and the point you made juicy about
an attachment you know
it's okay switch it up you know it's
okay to be honest with you something you
know what
this ain't really working out this
loadout for me you don't say it for this
map or whatever the situation
is and just try different things you
know and sometimes i've done that and
it's it's been to the you know
betterment for the team so
yeah absolutely any other questions for
our amazing guests sir drew no
no this has been our favorite segment
yeah you know like we
we had travis don't pvp i know like i
barely even need to be here i've already
got thrown under the bus
run over twice it's totally fine
that's funny because that's exactly what
your pvp teammates say about you when
you're on a team with them jesus christ
[Laughter]
i was like and banger there it is
all right dakota got well she she was
she wants to smoke
favorite raid drewski what do you what
do you top one or two raids for you
um favorite raids the ones that really
stick out of me is last wish and wrath
of the machine
i love the atmosphere and the uh
the atmosphere the exotics that came
from it and the
design of wrath of the machine it's like
and i love the music obviously from uh
in the riven fight from last wish the
grand scale of it like man
that music that which one specific part
of music two specific parts is like when
you're falling and shooting the weak
spots on ribbon
uh that music that plays like that
little string
right there you're like oh goosebumps
i'm like survivor
man and then there's the one part where
you have to stand on the plates in the
back
against axis and it goes like that crazy
intense operatic part
yes yes that was great yeah axis yeah
axis is very intense i like that uh let
me
access your music your music guy i got i
could buy but you are this
for me those two are great
last wish for me is churro chi
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
there just fine i get a shot here and
there thank you
brother take a shot it's all good oh
that music is super intense and then
leaving with the heart no
that like i i love that for um
wrath i think what we call them the
cable guy vasik
yeah that that would always that music
always made me i
always liked that one but yeah ray's got
they had some really
really good music like fanta bungee i
mean we'd even mention
queens the space the space yeah yeah
spacewalk i was gonna say like you're
holding your controller
all of you hold your controllers and you
just like set your controller down and
just listen to the spacewalk
that would be my number three i think
that's number three for me yes
it's amazing that's amazing that was
yeah the environment set up especially
if you get done with just the absolute
hell
because yeah aatrax for me was 12 hours
and then i quit and came back later and
then it got a little easier but yeah
then when you get up there the first
time
and gets just quiet the way they set it
up just everything's muffled
the music is just the focus and then
you're out there on the
just on the space station look at the
plane at the stars and it's just you
just kind of want to stop
everybody is like jumping along and part
of me just wants to like sit there and
look
and not do anything for a minute so
anyways after
churro chi we'll go ahead and move on
gotta get this man some dessert
that's fine
now i have an entire segment you can
live this one for five minutes okay
that's that seems at least somewhat fair
that's true
um man my comeuppance is gonna be real
bad when i get what's going on whenever
you
yeah whenever we get one on you oh man
that fires that bonfire is gonna be real
big
so anyway
cross play first before i even go into
all the details of how this is going to
work are you guys excited for this just
in general
yeah big time very much so beyond like
this is
huge huge do you have like a first
thing you're gonna do first friend
you're gonna play with first
i know somebody well besides me
i gotta get carried through pvp that's
what i gotta do right
listen man yeah and now now we're gonna
get to stomp people on four different
platforms
all at the same time it's gonna be right
wait can't wait what about you drew
just like wait wait wait yeah how
excited i'm really excited because i
bought a series x and uh i'm excited to
start like you know using that as my
main platform but still being able to
play with my pc friends right
i've been wanting to for a while like um
if i i
this might be outdated but i remember i
haven't i've only scanned through the
the recent swab
but uh the way that i understood uh
cross-plated work is like the consoles
have their like own pool and then
pc is like in its own like little world
but if you
join up on a pc player you're brought
into the pc world
so the pc world as many know is
inhibited by many
a cheater and uh for that reason
brand new information yeah right
so for that reason i wanted to go back
to console and um i did for a while but
there is a little
tiny bit of input delay that i'm like
not used to and uh i have a new
controller coming in
apparently the new series x controllers
and the latencies
yeah oh yeah absolutely exactly yeah so
i got a custom battle beaver coming in
i'm still waiting on very excited for
but i want to go all in with xbox and
play on my xbox as my main platform and
then like
still get the you know be able to play
with my pc friends um
so yeah that's what i'm excited for
salute rather yeah and
interestingly about the console pool is
that the
previous generation is also being merged
with the
current generation so series x and 1x
are going to be playing together ps4 and
ps5
all in the same pool which all those 30
frames guys
there were some exploits a couple months
ago i'm sure you guys remember this
where like
if you had one person playing on the
xbox one x or
uh one uh or one person playing on the
ps4 it would pull you into that pool and
people were using that to get trials
wins and stuff like that which you know
kind of cheesy but i think this was
during the height of stasis so people
were just looking for ways to like make
trials less toxic
um so yeah that's going to be really
good and a lot of people didn't have
new consoles yes that's true that is
true yeah yeah so they still don't
exactly
yeah they still don't that's that's very
true 10 million uh ps5s and who
who was able to buy these i don't know
there's 10 million people with the ps5
really
i feel like i know four people shout out
to the scout person
yeah yeah i'm excited for that massive
player pull for console
like i'm really really excited and then
stadium too
i believe yeah yeah the stadium people
are going to be sad
they're not safe to hide in their little
hustle stadium you can't hide
seven of them yeah the one entire team
in the solo game
came in fallout always on stadium like
you guys can be playing
console i can play console with you
but you keep playing stadia and now
they can just come play console yeah
nice
yep yeah let's get to it that's a lot of
info
we'll miss the wild west of the stadium
though that was really nice to have just
like this
weird group of players and some
sweat lords would go there just to like
it was like a
you know going to the caymans to hide
your money like it was just this weird
uh you know no man's land
in the stadium world thanks dudes going
over there to get flawless to avoid pc
cheating
it was it was a thing it was a thing
when it first came out for a little bit
for the pvp hardcore
the sweat lords were running over there
like you said it was like it was a
perfect analogy
you know it's really good that for me to
play with you guys i'm probably gonna
have to go to stadium
if you guys for cons
for me to use mouse and keyboard yeah
through
like stadia cause i pick up a controller
i may as well just like
hide in your backpack because me and a
controller is less than helpful
so it's like for me to actually play
with you guys sadly i swear stadiums
even the lag almost would be better than
a controller for me but why i mean we
would mostly be paying pve stuff like
if you play with pve it's fine but i'm
just saying if pvp and you guys
want to avoid cheaters if you join me on
pc you're in my world
so yeah that's the problem so yeah to me
i don't go crazy with it
in you know regular obviously yeah band
is gonna be a little bit but is that to
be
it's just trials to me i always felt
like yeah you see some weird
goofy stuff you know in iron banner on
occasion on pc
but i at least my experience i never
felt like
oh my god the majority of it was there
but when
we threw that trials on that oh
lord you're seeing on table stuff i'm
like that's not even humanly possible
with this product
flying around with automatic grenades
yeah no i've seen the clips that are
just ridiculous
that's when it really gets toxic because
you know the stakes are high
and people are doing what they got to do
but you know i would still
you know play play with you or you know
my pc guys at pvp just to do it you know
what i'm saying but we got to get into
the detail there's a lot of
a lot of stuff who am i
don't answer that question travis i
swear you'll just come up with something
crazy
but we are going to get back into the
kind of the steam naming schemes
honestly that we are the um
activision naming schemes that we had
before because you're going to have your
bungee name
which is going to be your player name
plus a number your display name
pretty standard the hash and your
numeric id so you're going to have
what you show up as is your number but
you're also going to have your bungee
name that'll work for cross play for
invites
for anything else and the big thing to
know about your name it seems like
is if you are like
gym rocket launcher sniper trace rifle
if all of
those have to come out and if you have
one of those
less than favorable names those are also
going to go through a filter and get
basically
if they don't work you're going gonna be
turned into guardian number seven
six five four three that's it you're
gonna be a generic guardian at that
point
so does anybody need to do any
like does anybody know anything anybody
who needs to do any name changing
in the next week or so
i'm trying not for me not speak but yes
definitely there's people in my clan who
are gonna have to change the name
because
on steam you can change your name like
you change your shirts you know yes you
just
you just change your name to the meme of
the week and that's just
what people do on that platform so
occasionally people will uh
you know spoof like just like oh i'm
gonna make my name lord cognito today
and just walk around
that guy uh i actually got yeah
my friend pranked me on a live stream
and and made their gamer tag the same as
somebody else i was trying to join for
the stream and then
yeah just just to mess with me i think
this is for the the
bungie charity stream that happened when
that fire was happening in australia
uh but yeah uh i so there's definitely
people that change my name but for me
i'm the same on every platform i think
pretty much everyone in this podcast has
that uh
you know branding across platforms so
we're probably safe but
it's gonna affect a lot of people on
steam for sure yeah for sure
change that kind of culture yeah extra
set ask can someone confirm if thigh
names yeah mars off thives
probably not something you want to stick
with permanently
mm-hmm my advice actually pick something
up it will work though
marisov's thighs i mean theoretically
it's just a name and thighs that's i
don't see the problem
technically would be okay thai girl
travis yes
travis already exists oh i know you just
yeah
yeah just gotta just gotta keep her
around there yeah
i wanted to say breakaway pants gym or
something like that
that's right
and uh we had sarah on and all of a
sudden
like because i don't know did you hear
this story because it was one of the
clips
and it was ty guy travis and ty girl
travis and like
she her ex had to change his name
because very small very small hat she
got popular and did her thing so he was
very large hat
and he's no longer he had to change his
things so it's like i was like travis
if she leaves you and she takes thai
girl ty guy travis like
because it's so attached to his wardrobe
he has to change his whole like look so
i was just gonna be like
[Music]
[Laughter]
you know like what's proceeding some
messy engagement he's gonna be t-shirt
travis
or something he's gonna have to change
everything so yeah
go by my middle name or something like
that jacket
jake i don't know it's messy man you
gotta gotta plan in advance sometimes
you gotta get those uh
those the gamertag name prenups
i guarantee you that's in her future
that's going to be that's going to be
our fight in our generation
what happens she gonna take half
for sure she just takes thai guy out man
that's it she just takes time
oh man well the big thing to note on the
timing of tv
yeah he only works at yeah see irl if
you get out of shape you got to change
your name
irl titans in there it's like i work out
to preserve my gamertag yeah
salute right yeah no if you don't if you
don't have those arms you're gonna have
to change your whole tag
to you know people or something like
that yeah that's what i was gonna say
it's important
disrespectful noodle arm hunter
shout out to the titan but yeah
definitely think about your name because
when you log into season 15 for the
first time in whatever platform you log
on
that's what's going to go through their
system so remember the timing
august 24th you're going to be watching
the trailers hype is going to be
happening
figure it out before then just my piece
of advice
um as for friends the bungee roster is
still gonna work
they've showed that the way you're gonna
be able to find your friends
um you're gonna be able to see what
platforms they're on you're gonna be
able to use their bungee
basic name to add people to it uh but
the big thing
is like the bungee name's gonna be there
you know your friends are gonna be there
what's your name on this platform here's
my bungee name and you'll be attached
roster system does look like it's gonna
be the same but the big one
is matchmaking that's probably the
biggest one of all of these things
and pc players will match with other pc
players
console players will match with other
console players note
stadium will be in the console pool fire
teams with any combination of pc players
and console players will match in the
pc pool pve
everybody hmm
let's talk about it what you feeling man
do you feel that is handled well any
changes you'd make
are you worried about people exploiting
anything
um uh
i i think that's handled pretty
decently i mean okay so here's the only
thing that
criticism i'd give is
i feel maybe they could have done
matchmaking based on input
so if i'm in controller player on pc
i can still play with controller players
while on console right
because i mean i've i've played like pc
and con like my
my pc runs like my series x like there's
no
like real disparity other than like the
controller delay i talked about earlier
which is like going to be
like resolved with the new controller
right um
like so i i they're pretty level playing
field i want to say
so uh you know matchmaking based on
input maybe you could have maximized
that
player pool uh quite a bit however
um they're in destiny you can swap input
methods on the fly it's not like other
games so like other games call of duty i
know i believe
halo will be doing that as well the
input based matchmaking
um in those games like you're committed
to the like you you have to like go to
your settings and say like
change like i'm playing on this input
right now
um and you and you can't change that in
game obviously
so destiny doesn't work like that like
you just switch the input and it starts
working
so i suppose if they weren't keen on
changing that then this is the best
solution
uh the icing on the cake or like the
silver lining of this perhaps
is uh that you know at the very least
even if you are a controller on pc i'm
sure there are some people that
will still find a way to cheat and you
can be sure that in the console pool
you're
most likely not dealing with any of that
per se at least i would hope
so i guess that's the good that comes
out of the way they've decided to go
about it
yeah yeah i think they're trying to put
a wall up between pc and console mostly
for the cheaters
yeah it still sucks the pc cheaters is
going to be
no better but it does t preserve the
console
space as a safer space for probably
their bigger player base
on the whole steam's not small everybody
else together
four five series x one stadia
the other seven people that got thrown
in all of those
all of that is still gonna be the
biggest shout out to the seventh yeah
all of those is still gonna be the
biggest pool and that's still probably
gonna be the safest so it's like i get
what they were going for but as you said
i didn't actually think about the input
because i'm almost mouse and keyboard
but i guess if you're pc
and controller they still have to debate
about the cheating part which i guess
gets to be interesting
yeah yeah i'm so excited i'm sorry
no go ahead okay no no i'm just gonna
reiterate what you said
you know i i mean after i thought about
it i i actually really like it i
actually really like
the the choice they made um you know
especially with the mixed fire team you
know
because i ain't a lot you know some
people gonna have delusions like yo if i
get the top
pc dude on my squad to come over here
casa
you know and think they're gonna stay in
the console pool and just wreck
like you know look they i like that you
automatically
move into the pool i think overall this
is great i i just
i just love that it's going to be this
in in its influx
of of of of players and search
stadia y'all just got blessed
let me just explain steady i tried like
doing a strike
in stadia was a chore just to get
two other people whoever's like
dedicated to stadia
the influx that they're gonna have is is
tremendous and i
just you know from a console standpoint
you know being an xbox primarily you
know playing
just to be able to you know to have the
the you know the ps the playstation guys
in there
that's gonna be great and forget like in
pve just universal
everybody like pools and engagement is
gonna be
so good like that's to me that's why
like even though i know we we complain a
lot about
you know the the com when which queen
got delayed and we know the content
drought
the extra long season you know we're
dreading it right because we know they
got to stretch things out
but to me this is a thing that's really
going to help
during that dry spell i love it i think
i think this is pretty good
good you know i mean obviously like
drewski said we still got to see you
know if anything can be exploited you
know they'll try to be faster than
trigger with it
but um i i couldn't be honest i was like
you know what this is pretty fair to me
i
i couldn't really complain too too much
what do you what do you think trap
yeah i think it looks good on paper but
i don't think it'll work like it is
written
i think you know the like last time they
tried to do cross-play they enabled
12-person raids
right like like this this
yeah i remember that whole thing like i
i think people will find ways around it
i think people
pc players will find a way into the
console pool or
uh console only fire teams will get
matched with pc
players and i just think it's gonna be
rocky and the reason i think that is
because
every game that has tried to do cross
play has had issues
it's really hard lots of people are
finding out um
yeah and if you guys if you guys have
played a game that has a cross play it's
always
really rocky right when they they first
implement it so
i think we'll probably get there
eventually i do think there needs to be
a great
firewall uh between uh
console and pc just because of the
cheaters um
and the the input doesn't bother me too
much just because like
you know i'm a guy who when i play on pc
i play with controller and i do fine i i
don't think it's that big of an
advantage
but i do think that the the biggest
thing between playing on pc and console
on controller is they actually act
differently you get less
recoil when you play on pc on a
controller and so
i think it makes sense to kind of keep
those separated because otherwise
it's not a super level uh playing field
more than the input is just that the
games operate differently on pc and
consoles so
i get why they're separated i am very
excited to have playstation players in
xbox pool because they are not good at
crucible
and i am really excited to stomp on them
uh
dude you want easy mode go go play with
those guys who have those
unstaggered sticks on their controller
because they do not know what they're
doing
uh though you really go fast
dude i'm not fan i'm not fanboying i mix
i'm
just saying i have i have a playstation
5 i have an xbox series x i play on both
of them i'm just saying in my
professional experience
when i want to stomp i go to the
playstation platform because that's
where those players play they're a lot
of pve players they're not very good at
pvp that's just been my experience
messy track maybe it's because i have
less uh less
pvp play time on the playstation
platform and so i'm in that's
probably your match
yeah if it's cross play because we
already have cross save right so
do they take the do they take my stats
on xbox and apply it to the playstation
i don't really know but uh
yeah that's just that's just been my
experience so uh but yeah i i think in
theory it's good i just think that it's
probably not going to work right out the
gate just based on
the test specs and just based on yeah i
think there will be growing pains and i
think they'll probably be prolonged
i could even see them disabling
a little bit uh cross play for pvp i
think that that might happen where
they go all right well it's up and
running it's working on pvp pve but
there's some
exploit on the pvp side so yeah we'll
turn it off
or whatever i could see stuff like that
i could see i could see something like
that happening i think it's going to be
i mean but to me no i mean you could you
could be valid here i mean
to me hopefully it's no different than
you know them implementing like
turning the exotic off for the weekend
you know like
hopefully they have the safeguards in
place so that if the exploits do happen
to what you are saying and
what possibly alluding to that they have
something in place
ahead of time to be able to be a quick
disabled
and you know it doesn't break the
infrastructure game but i'm curious for
eve because
you know it's mouse and keyboard you
know this is this is that's his realm
like
i mean i'm stuck on pc that's just
nothing's changing for me i'm still
playing with pc mouse and keyboard and
if i go into pvp and i
if i choose to try and find a backpack
for trials there's probably going to be
some cheaters in there so it's like my
world doesn't change
it just broadens the console pool a lot
which is good for everybody else
i actually meant pve because you're
primarily no i mean for me it's going to
be great like if i'm on stream or like
new rad or black wings or dakota like a
lot of the people that i know
in chat that are like always there and
they just joke to be like hey let's go
run something now i can just be like
here's here's finally the bungee number
you know here's my bungee code add it in
and now let's just go play
like that for any content creator
streamer
i mean the people who do like helps and
stuff like that all those types of
things that's what i'm saying for the
streamers the content creators that's
huge because you'd be like hey do you
want to join here's the no
like here's the number now what they
need and i don't know if it's listed the
same way it is like your steam
like game id because you're not going to
want to have like an infinite friends
list
of bungee friends like theoretically i
mean it depends because
people on friends list depending on who
they are you know that there have been
weird exploits where somebody was a
friend and later they screwed up it was
like
cathalyan and broman they like ddos them
in the middle of the raid because they
like joined them up and
so stuff like that like if you need if
you can have a
cross play just a game join something
like that
is something that they probably need to
make sure especially just for the
content creators because yeah somebody
wants to run in help somebody through a
gm nightfall
i can get them in for the session that
doesn't mean they need to be on my
friend's little list for life or i need
to go trim that up later on
so that would be something people
associate you huh
no not even for me i'm honestly thinking
of like people who like
help people for hours and hours and
hours if you do that it's like there are
service dreamers there's a lot of them
that are doing amazing work
but like you don't necessarily want to
add them no yeah
at some point that list gets
unmanageable that's all like if you
keep adding and adding and adding so i
don't know if that's something they're
thinking about
have mentioned if there's going to be
like a join because i mean outriders
while it wasn't perfect they had like
that joint code for your session or
whatever
so i don't know if they'll figure
something out like that or if it's got
to be the bungee id
i don't know so we'll have to see if
there's a way they manage that or if you
just have to be kind of diligent with
the friends list
because i mean for the service streamer
for the content creator
for anybody who's on and i'm just
playing and be like all right i'm going
to go run a dungeon anybody want to join
and it doesn't matter who is in chat
if you have destiny you can do it that's
going to be the best part
it's amazing like that's so good yeah so
i mean i just hope they give you these
bounties will now be universal yeah
for each platform oh yeah that's one
that i was thinking about earlier
think about that uh yeah there's gonna
be just a lot of stuff that's just
more simple now it will also make it
impossible for bungie to reverse their
decision on
platform exclusivity uh you know giving
uh
exotics or maps yes i think that's long
done
you know and the chips are down maybe
they make a deal with destiny three or i
don't know but if they're committed to
crosstalk
microsoft back that money truck up i've
been saying it
i i don't i don't think i think it's too
late for anyone include including
microsoft i don't think that's uh
really helps them at all to to i
strongly disagree
it is funny though because you're really
quiet are you talking about acquiring
yeah why not why would it make business
sense for them when they're getting all
of their games
already you mean microsoft or for bungie
yeah no i'm saying who are you asking no
i think
for for bungie hypothetically they're
good right now right
but hypothetically for for microsoft
obviously it fits the model when they
when they did
game pass you want those type of games
that's going to have that consistent
engagement when they did beyond light
they did tremendous
with with their um player numbers and
stuff like that
that game kind of destiny suits a game
pass model
in my opinion right and then you can put
microsoft access obviously tess is
already out here he doesn't say that
kind of thing
now for bungie's standpoint to me the
only reason why i say it
look they can stay how they are i'm fine
i wouldn't be mad if it happened because
my main issue has always been the
content stream the issue is
we consume the content too fast that
they think can make it so
if they had the resources and the
backing to do it
then by all means i would absolutely
love it because that's the only issue
right now it's just like we're like damn
you know it just takes a while and now
they're independent
i mean for as much as we complained
about activision's
practices which were not the greatest
we have to admit during that time we
were getting
the forsakens the taken kings we were
getting those
big meaty expansions yeah studios in the
mix so yeah right
and then you had the support studios you
had the what is it uh high moves
vicarious visions vicarious visions
that's
the stuff that microsoft could do with
xbox game studios if they need
extra help and they would get more money
and resources so all i care about is
they're making content not having the
droughts and oh which queen is delayed
and now this
is this and now you know that that's the
only thing that them being independent
the burden is a lot on them but again
if it happens great if it doesn't happen
i mean i'm still good but
i would i would be like i feel that i i
guess i guess my comment was more that
like
it doesn't make sense for microsoft to
acquire them because in bungie they
already have a partner that's willing to
put their game on game pass and keep it
there indefinitely apparently so like
microsoft's already getting all the
benefits they would get if they acquired
it
and then on the other hand that the
people at bungie are getting everything
that they want from microsoft which is
presumably money to make their game
because they're
on game pass so you know that
microsoft's probably paying them
uh a stipend every every month or year
or however they have an analogy
and then yeah and i also think that when
it comes to
the amount of content i think the reason
there's not going to be any more
forsakens
it has a lot to do obviously with the
fact that activision's not in the
picture anymore
but i think it also has to do with the
fact that it wasn't a sustainable model
and i think
everyone at bungie talked about that
about how like that sprint
to make content and the i'm sure they
were doing like
a lot of crunch and all that i think
that was
kind of the problem and having to meet
those deadlines and then
shipping stuff before it was ready
because you had to hit those deadlines
including
destiny vanilla including destiny 2
pretty much every
uh release that they came out with
except for forsaken
and the taking king felt like it was
half baked and could have used more time
in the
oven and all that stuff so uh i i don't
know that them having more fun
more money and more teams to support
them would necessarily solve the problem
of
you know that model wasn't really
working for them so uh that that's just
my thought but i i definitely agree that
there are there are opportunities to
to work together certainly and if if i
think bungie knows
probably in their back pocket that if
ever a day came where they
they felt like they couldn't do it on
their own they like that i mean phil
spencer plays like
thousands literally yeah
like there's no way that that that uh
pete parsons doesn't have yeah those two
talk
number one yeah yeah he's got he's got
he's got phil spencer's cell phone
number underneath a glass with a little
hammer
next to it in case in case of
it's interesting like i said i just feel
it's a direct result
all of a sudden the switch to the
seasonal model was after
they broke free and i just feel that
once those support studios
were gone you know it's a it's a big
burden
it's a bit it's a lot it's a it's a huge
game with a tremendous base that
it's very demanding for them to keep up
but again
as to your original point i think i use
the analogy it's like
what's that is it italian like would you
you'll get the milk with the
you know that one where it's like you're
dating someone why buy the cow and you
can get the milk
there you go so it's like yeah yeah you
know what i'm saying friends with
benefits
right now so it's no need to necessarily
put a ring on it necessarily because
both would kind of get what they want
right now you know that kind of thing
but i see what you said
all the analogies aside
uh chatting with your first app no it
works um
there's probably an app for that but
chatting with your friends is gonna be
another thing
because cross play and we had this
discussion shout out to d flawless
and his fantastic little tick tock about
all the people breaking your ears with
what they're doing all that stuff is
just crazy so
um when crossplay releases voices
listens to the show apparently
yes look dude with the defaults
we turned our skit into reality yeah we
have some run into some late breaking
issues with the development are
currently working on making sure
the experience is ready for voice chat
between all platforms so it is something
they will be shipping
later i think that one's coming in the
winter if i look at the schedule
um basically they say soon after launch
actually that one's going to be fairly
close
but they also mentioned text chat is
critical to communication so pc you got
keyboards
they're gonna allow later on in the
winter usb keyboards
for chat for consoles if they allow them
only for chat not for gameplay that's
the one when somebody
i was like that's what i'm what no
that's when i'm wondering honestly if
when somebody's going to try and break
it right
do some weird exploit to get the
keyboard and mouse popping on console
and people are in there like
like modding their series x's i honestly
don't know how much you could if they
control the inputs on those for
text chat only takes these input doesn't
take the other way on console but there
are some smart people out there breaking
stuff so i would
i i'd be i'd be willing to bet there's a
teddy are already out there playing with
a key mouse and keyboard on
uh xbox probably be surprised like today
like yeah i would just wouldn't be
surprised if that was already a thing so
um but they are working on it but that
kind of is a thing for communication
because if it's like hey coming to the
discord hey jump in here
hey voice chat or whatever platforms are
still going to be the thing where it's
you can play with other people but
where are you going to talk with your
friends yeah so that's going to be the
interesting point and that's where
if who knows when sony's gonna do its
discord thing
but discord is kind of that universal
platform from pc
so if you have somebody piecing your
party i know there's a lot of people
that are gonna start making a discord
app
get the discord app on your phone plug
it in you're good as you said
if it could be on both on the consoles
and just this universal thing
that would solve all of this without
even the need for like in-game because
the in-game voice chat is trash anyway
like the quality because you guys we
sound reasonable in this discord chat
obviously because the quality's there
but when you go and do
game chat it sounds like you're talking
through a bucket so yeah let me ask you
something if you don't mind um in
reference to this with the
you know obviously i would assume we're
all a little disappointed
it the the in-game chat's not ready
right so like drewski for you i was
gonna ask you like
you know ask someone now you said you're
gonna be on series x you're gonna be you
know on console
most likely doing it up for the
crossplace stuff like are you
like is that you're gonna be your
solution for for the the cross-plate
people that you play with like how are
you gonna handle that situation
um i'm probably gonna stick to discord i
still have my pc of course to use so
generally discord's my home to
communicate
with folks no doubt no doubt no doubt
and uh e everybody's we just go ahead
and discard it out until you announce it
i mean it's the easiest one that's
universal because you can get it on your
phone
you can get on your pc so at least those
two can play if you got an earbud
a headset i mean travis has literally
got one that's like it's a you know not
even an inch big
or barely and just tuck in here and
there you go you're done
so if you got game audio on one side
that one and the other
the best one you could probably do is if
you have a headset i haven't used one in
a while but if you have a bluetooth
headset
connect that to your phone get the voice
chat in there that's just about to say
yeah and then also
have it take the game audio i used to do
that with the set headset i previously
would use i just have it set up
differently now
and that was worked perfect that would
work perfectly so if you have
like bluetooth headsets and stuff with
the ones that you like take both audio
that they can play at the same time
that'd be
great for xbox guys i highly advise
the default the new xbox uh wireless
headset the one that they just came out
because you have that ability and you
can adjust you can have
i've connected it to my phone before
i've watched a youtube video listen to
that you know so
you can apply that same logic you know
your discord app
have that on and you can mix and adjust
the uh the sound levels on both
so you can you know get that going on
because i know this is gonna be it's
gonna be a lot for console guys to
to acclimate yeah that's what i was
gonna
that's what i was gonna touch on this i
think this is a huge huge miss and i
think it's gonna be a nightmare
i really do well they say soon after
launch the question is when
right yeah but i mean even even if they
come up with a solution for it which i'm
not
i'm not confident there will be one that
is like universally
understood like you know unless it's
just
a replacement for game chat that
actually works across the board
uh which i think would be fine but even
then you still have problems with like
people wanting to be in parties and uh
quality versus
uh usability and that sort of thing but
i think
like between us like if i'm playing with
e it's easy because i'll figure out a
workaround
but if if you're telling players okay
well you got to get discord
okay well that's an app what is discord
a lot of console players are going to
ask you all right well now i've got to
make an account
and connect it to my other accounts and
then i need to find your username
which is a separate username from your
what what i'm calling you in destiny
uh and then we all have to be in a party
together and then oh
you want me to have an earbud on one
side and then a headset on the other
that's staggered on my face so that it's
not covered oh
oh you want you want me to buy a headset
that can do bluetooth and
xbox wireless communication so that i
can have two channels of communication
at once
like you guys do not understand yeah
like gobbledygook to a console player
and even to pc players i'm sure a lot of
them are just like
doing what they're they're told oh okay
this is easy i can set them a couple
minutes but it it's gonna be a nightmare
and i didn't even want to think about
like what is the solution for stadia
does stadium even have a headset
because i have a console what do you do
for that like i have
no idea what the solution is for for a
stadia player so
it it gets so complicated so quick and i
think
even after this patch is deployed
there's no way it's going to meet the
demands of the player base
or be user-friendly or usable and i
think that that is effectively going to
mean
that a lot of people don't use
cross-play they at least don't use it
casually you're not going to see any
lfgs that are cross-play
because of that specifically oh we found
somebody in lfg but he's from a
different platform well now we all have
to do this dance for 20 minutes
to get them on the right voice channel
to talk to the rest of us
there's no way people are going to want
to do that in an lfg so they're just
going to say
i'm just saying this is
i would love to see them implement game
chat in a way that's comprehensive and
make sense but what if you have a stadia
player
are stadia players just just nixed now
because what what does stadium players
do for they have to have some microphone
input theoretically right they gotta
have a microphone everybody so they use
discord
they use discord that's that's what i
did when i was on studios you use
discord stuff okay but you still have a
microphone so stadia has to be able to
pick up a microphone
what is the microphone attached to it's
it's big device are you plugging the
microphone browser so it's acting like a
piece
sometimes it's pc it's not always pc it
could be your phone
do they even have i don't are they oh
yeah they do have do they have the
mobile
yeah you can play it on your phone so
and then
it's just it's gonna be i'm just saying
man
i i see this coming a mile away there's
gonna be some
stuff here that doesn't work and even if
it does work
it's going to be a hassle for people and
it's going to make people not want to
play with certain types of players
i can see the the stadium people
becoming black sheep
in this equation you know or like i just
six months from now who was right about
this one because i think i'm right i
really didn't i mean by the time which
queen comes out
the game chat has got to be smooth
that's one of those things by the time
which queen
launches the in cross platform voice
chat they say soon after season 15
launched
yeah they've got a plan they found like
one so that should
and again wherever you're playing
whether if you're playing on your phone
whatever you're playing
they all have microphones somehow if you
don't have a microphone you got to have
a microphone somewhere so
if that works and then and then the
quality of the microphone now that's a
whole different thing
here we go no no that's that that gets
to my point though because people aren't
going to want people there
if it's like this low quality
quality and non-functionality that's
two different yeah that's a different
argument i'm just saying compatibility
is gonna be wrong as a music person and
something with like
ears that are in tune how important is
audio quality to you
uh i mean in the context of gaming i
guess is like i'm never gonna
like say no to good quality but if like
if you if
if what you got is what you got i mean
we just gotta be able to
i mean i don't know i i i think quality
is great when i can get it but if as
long as we can communicate i'll take
communication overnight
i guess my neuroses are showing
yeah i was like you're gonna have some
quality sometimes you're gonna have the
earbud that's got a blender in the
background you're gonna have some funky
moments
sure don't get me wrong be like hey
somebody in chat you want to come in
and there's there in your ear and you're
like what what do i hear
right now and it's there's going to be
some of those moments no doubt about it
those glam but on the other side
you're going to have people with an
earbud connected to their phone on
discord and then you're going to hear
all the sounds coming out of their tv
and you're going to be like yo can you
turn down the volume on your tv so that
i don't have to
hear you kill every single fallen and
they're going to be like oh
what word and it's just it's going to be
a nightmare for six or seven months
that's what this is he he
just sanded racing for the horrible
quality this is what this one this
man is dreading the these were
they went to the bathroom they forgot
the mute oh god that clip
did you see that drew did you see glad's
tweet i did
no i didn't oh a guy went he was playing
new world or something was in a party
with somebody
and all of a sudden some dude left his
wireless headset mike on
and just was in the bathroom just
destroying it
and he clipped the whole thing and put
it on twitter and it is
hilarious because it's just like so
perfectly captured but yeah that's the
moment when you're like oh god what am i
listening to
but yeah it's all those things going on
that you guys are talking about because
you know destroying a bathroom
somebody's microwaving food over here
somebody's eating out of a bag of chips
chomping on something
which i don't even think about then you
said it which was hilarious um
yeah d flawless nailed that one but he's
just like take a minute get your stuff
together
let's go i love the end of that one um
but again we'll have text chat
so that'll be there a little bit your
text voice chat will be coming
overall i think a lot of this is
positive because when i played the
matchmaking strike playlist that they
did if i was matched with anybody on
those i never felt it
now i was like i don't know if anybody
else felt anything but i mean i had you
know a couple guys in
in my discord and stuff they played
outriders cross play and they were like
there was lag it was pretty bad stuff
like that didn't go too well
oh yeah like if they can get the cross
play to
play smooth which hopefully their test
worked in anything that they've been
getting set up
if the gameplay can be smooth and if the
voice chat at least in game is
functional that's gonna be a pretty
solid step
will it be perfect no are are travis's
ears gonna melt off the side of his head
yes
but in the end this hopefully
if if it goes smoothly is the big giant
question because lately
things can tend to launch imperfectly
bugs
hiccups and that's just like i don't
know if it's like people have wondered
like are you guys cueing it of course
they're cooling it but again it's the
time the bandwidth and everything else
that's why i keep saying take your time
on which queen if it does go relatively
smooth
if the voice chat gets in there at lunch
it's going to be really annoying to be
like i could go in game chat now but
it's it is going to be one of those
things you end up probably doing to make
life easy
so there's a couple things i mean not
excuse me not building up your friends
list the voice chat will have to see how
it goes but if they can iron some of
this stuff out now
they have six months before witch queen
which queen could be a smooth lunch
which is why they are doing this now i
think
yep there's no question so glad which
queen isn't coming out this year
because they need this time to work out
otherwise it's going to be like the
outriders launch cog where you were
on uh stranded on gilligan's island what
do you mean
yeah my my brief box of briefs for like
with no luke
at my screen i can't launch the game no
you're right i mean that's the beauty
i completely agree with you on that
travis because like that's the beauty
of it launching it now during this dead
period this extended season where
witchcreen is delayed and work out the
kinks take as much time as you yeah you
can
i'm with e though in the sense that the
fact that they said
soon after launch with the cross chat
gives me confident that that's pretty
much ready
you know i was actually surprised the um
that what you call the tech stuff
um was it you know i mean because i'm
like damn that's
being on pc that's a really cool
feature especially when you're playing
with randall's and you know you just
match megan it's just like hey man
someone sent you a quick like console
needs that i always felt that's
a pc always had the better quality of
life
with that and um shout out to screen so
never tell me there's no
content i will fight yes we know you
will find contest sir um
but um yeah like i think it's i can't
wait for that and then with xbox trap
like they have
the uh the ch actually use my chat pad
again that connects to the controller
and stuff like that so i can't wait to
use you know that chat functionality but
yeah we got we got to see how this thing
plays out
i just like that they got that long
season
to mess around to fix what needs fixing
disable what needs disabling and
implement the right way and hopefully
by which queen we get that refined
product with the new content and the new
stuff so
i'm pulling from them i think they i
think they're going to do it i'm a
little more positive
than trav on this
remember what i told run the tape
yeah no i'm gonna i want this clipped
and i want it ready to play on demand
uh when we when we have this final talk
about it but i i i'll say is i'm really
glad they're gonna have a lot of time to
iron it out i think they will need it
and i think uh this is this will be
season of the cross play like that's
really what this next six months is
gonna be about like it's gonna be about
them getting this
this stuff right so that they can uh
they can launch witch queen and do it
right
i mean i think that's probably kind of a
perfect little segue there
because honestly i wanted to ask um
all of you guys but drew as well as we
do have the looming season of the
question mark
that is gonna be a lengthy one um what
are your thoughts about looking at a six
month season
possibly we don't know but that's you
know everybody's speculating
uh crossplay being in there is this a
point where somebody even like you
who will definitely stream a lot of
destiny and stuff like that is this a
point where you
stick with destiny for the six months
still living in the pvp world do you
take breaks of playing other things
what does this season look like for you
coming up because it's not gonna be a
short one
um i'm not sure i always thought that
this season coming up
although it's gonna be a lengthy one
seems promising
they've been relatively open about
talking about things at least in the
sandbox
as far as i'm aware that are coming and
their attention on it and
as much as they've said some of these
changes and the frequency of these
changes is not expected to be normal
they did say that things like you know
when they did the dmt
changes and like once these mid season
changes they said there's going to be
you know follow up to that as well or
like in that twab and they talked about
a bunch of things that are on the radar
so that keeps me hopeful that we'll
hopefully really see
some mid-season changes that
still allow the sandbox to be good in
terms of a
pvp sense um for me
uh like i i
don't like a lot of things about trials
but among my most hated things
um even more than cheaters is third
person peaking
and that's i believe that's going away
in season 15 if i'm not mistaken yeah
thank god so thank god that combined
with like cross play so at least i can
get away from the cheers a little bit
more and even then like your cheaters to
me it's just like all right guys cool
enjoy your win we re-cue restart great
whatever i understand how that could be
a little bit more daunting for some
other players that like you know
were really far in that card and like
you know yeah it had to you know like it
really took a lot
i i get it uh fortunately for me i i
don't i'm not really phased by it i'm
just like yeah whatever all right take
it away and enjoy i don't know what you
enjoy about that but
have fun and like just move on to the
next game for me the third person
peaking is really what kills it to me
uh so that's going to be gone and even
just to avoid the cheaters i get to play
on consoles so
uh that alone will uh give me many
hours of enjoyment um but as far as like
a long season goes i don't know man like
it
i i'm a big advocate for like if the
meta is healthy and enjoyable
the game will continue to be enjoyable
at least in terms of pvp
so like i think it'll be fine
um it's always a little like i guess
nerve-wracking because
destiny for many people is a game that's
like that lives based on the content
what there is to do and like the
relevancy of it uh
and being new content and things to
chase but um
like i said we saw a lot of things this
season mid-season
in terms of like weapons being reprised
new things that were
reprised things to chase mid-season
patches and i just don't see
a season that long happening without
things like that in place uh so i'm sure
they're well aware of that kind of stuff
so
uh i i think it'll be fine and like i
said if the met is healthy
and if the meta is good if it's fun to
play people will keep playing i think at
least i'll keep playing
so november 12th halo infinite drops
what do you do
oh i mean in that case i'm definitely
i'm definitely
i'm definitely playing some information
oh we do that infinite that's right
yeah yeah for sure i think this is going
to be something
so long
i mean that is going to be about that
time because you got you know
late august it launches late september
late october late november
that's a normal season length so i don't
i was going to say
i don't expect anything more
content-wise than we've had in these
previous seasons just because the delay
is there i don't expect
them building you know 24 weeks of
content
or story blips i mean you want to talk
about drip feeding before god they can't
make it worse
so they need to still deliver the story
in a normal time frame they're eight to
ten weeks that they do
it's just going to be that seas the
weekly challenges you're gonna have six
months to do it
but that's going to be the point where i
mean yeah halo infinite
and anything else that comes out between
now and then is going to give you that
time
chibi's mentioned like final fantasy 14
which is stupid busy right now
there's a lot of other things and i i
i'm wondering how as you said drewski if
it's feeling good
if trials is good you know if we do i
mean we're gonna have sadly festival
lost and the dawning we know those are
coming i don't expect a lot from them
don't remind me but i don't expect big
changes in those
so we'll be like everybody will kind of
tune in get the things check the boxes
kind of pop in and out battlefield looks
fun
with portal and everything to make crazy
crazy games
so there's other things going on and i
think
partially the delay is going to work in
bungie's favor
people are going to be like oh no
there's the content drought and people
are going to be but if people can like
do the human thing and go play something
else they get a little refresher
when it hits in the relatively quiet
because games come out all the time now
but the relatively quiet
january february march time frame
there's not going to be nearly
everything around it that there normally
is because normal it's like hey bunchie
might come out
and then you got call of duty this red
dead redemption grand theft auto so many
things fall in that
fault that's always been the craziest
month for basically anybody in gaming
so now we go to winter when you're just
getting done with the holidays kind of
settling back in
february bam here's a new season there's
not a lot that's going to compete with
that
actually um because again
speculation what what i mean for you
especially i'm just thinking about you
because i know
you you missed a single player you like
to get your your stuff on sony stuff
might be front loaded at the top of the
year too i heard we've got a lot of
because we're hearing harassing
yeah we're hearing that and to me that's
going to set up a phenomenal
uh 2022 beginning of the year for them
possibly
if that got a border in the same year
are you kidding yeah that's a phenomenal
year that's crazy
me and maddie were talking about that so
you got that but now to your point i
mean
yeah i mean it's it's it's going to be
interesting to see
how this season plays out you know for
me
my they already gave me my content which
is this announcement cross plays by
content
i mean that's what i think they're going
to put a lot of i think that's what
they're probably betting a decent amount
on is this like cross play connecting
with people
hey you haven't played in a while
depending on what we hear on the 24th
about
whatever it's going to be for which
queen or whatever we get a tease of
um this will be the season of hey it's
quiet right now
you got to break between games you want
to jump back in witch queen's about to
get absolutely bonkers
i can play with you whatever console you
got those types of connections i think
is
partially what they're hoping this
season is filled with
yeah i mean that's what i make if i give
a travis um i
to me what would be key is with this
crowd if
pvp is actually addressed in
some way and like drewski is saying the
met is cleaned up the three pekings out
now you got bigger trials pools you got
bigger pools
where it's not super sweaty and the met
is balanced
fairly then it could be fun
and then but what if you gave us a map i
mean maybe i'm asking too much
maybe i'll maybe reach it for this one
yeah i i think that what's gonna what my
expectation would be is like
probably not like too much i think that
um some
sandbox shakeups they they talked about
a lot of things and it's hard to
remember um
i don't know if like subclasses were
mentioned i'm not i'm not sure there was
so many yeah things mentioned of like
what they had their eyes on
for changes and like uh in this in that
one
massive twab um and then like they
uh um chris and uh kevin joined us
on the firing range podcast amazing
episode we didn't even talk about fire
rates you guys killed that
yeah i listened to that amazing thing
yeah like those kind of insights like
and i don't know how soon whatever it is
like i
all this information gets jumbled up in
my head right but um
i i think if there are some refreshers
or things being refreshed
um as a result of that i kind of expect
a little bit of that
um so some new some like appropriate
balancing i'm sure
um in follow-up balancing i expect that
to happen and i i think that refreshes
the game for a lot of people
um the the the cross-play thing even if
even if people do fall off i expect
cross play to be their bet that it'll
keep the game
feeling healthy like yeah a few times
are still going to feel healthy the
majority of the time
and you're gonna have people to play
with so i think that's a major bet and
then i think the most that we can
content-wise when i say like mid-season
content i mean uh not like you know
new new things but probably i'd imagine
they're gonna bring back some uh
so like reprise some weapons again like
we saw the dreaming city and like moon
weapons come back
i wouldn't doubt that we're gonna see
like some weapons return with just new
perks and
just to chase which is cool truth to me
i don't you know i i don't think it's
bad either to go play like a different
game like you know
infinite's gonna come out man i'm gonna
play a bunch of infinite like this is
how it goes and then like destiny will
be popping we're gonna be back on it
oh no juicy but is it too much for me
and travis to ask
for one new crucible map
is it is it is am i out of line
for asking you know i'll raise you this
um so
everyone's talking about like there
hasn't been a new
map in this many days and i this might
be a hot take but
i don't care for a new map
so much as i care for new game modes and
i actually think that it's
probably easier to develop to develop i
you know i'm not a developer and i don't
know whatsoever i
i could be completely wrong about this
but i'd imagine it's
easier uh to develop a new game mode
than it is a new map and i think the
destiny is in dire need of new game
modes and i think
the a game mode or a good game mode has
the power to change
completely a way that a map is played
because currently what we have in
destiny is like 50 different flavors of
slayer or clash
even control is clash everything is just
kill centric
there's no true objective game modes
there's no
major like focal points like you say in
halo you have capture the flag you have
like
in cod you got hardpoint you had uplink
uh
you know like we don't have those things
we don't even have rift anymore
right like so i think
game modes uh have the power
probably less resource intensive for
them and still have the power to shake
up how
current maps feel and bring bring new
like diversity to the game so like
i don't know like i'm cool with the map
but like i'm still gonna be if we got a
new map i'm not gonna say no
i'm gonna say oh awesome but then i'm
gonna still say all right and i have
like 50 different flavors of clash to
play on this map
it's just like is there a type of scale
no matter what
is there a type of mode that you would
like to see
first like what do you think would be
most beneficial to the game
i mean rift is want to hear about a lot
but is there
anything else that they may not be
thinking of or people don't generally
think about what mode would you like to
see
i think that um i mean if i think the d1
modes are the most logical just because
that that feels familiar and we feel
like you know they
they have maybe again i'm not a dev here
but like the tech already
kind of sort of there somehow some ways
so like it seems within reach
so my only problem with the d1 game
modes was that
again i think their scoring was just
wrong i don't think you should have
gotten points for progress or kills and
rift
it should just be you dunk the ball you
get a point
you know it's pretty pretty
self-explanatory type of thing uh and i
think that salvage was kind of cool
other than i think that
uh the scoring was flawed to be more
favorable if you
like didn't plant or something like that
anyways it should be you plant you get a
point you don't plan well you don't get
a point or like
you don't successfully blow up the plant
or whatever you don't get a point
uh those gamers i think would be awesome
if i had to like
like hand pick a game that we've never
seen in destiny it would be capture the
flag or
oddball from halo i think would be
really cool like to have like a really
you know like in halo you have like a
little skull
if we had like a really cool like relic
of some sort of destiny
to like hold as like the ball like i
think that would just be kind of cool
or juggernaut where you just get your
super constantly and have damage
resistance of eighty percent
you know and you just yeah i mean like
more ways to play the game that isn't
just clash
and like 80 different ways to play clash
well i just wish they would do something
to wear that's right and i think part of
the sandbox is the issue with this but
you see something like battlefield with
portal
make you'll they'll have like four you
know
modern 2042 soldiers versus the
battlefield one soldiers it's like four
verse 100
but they have a machine gun and they
have these old bolt action rifles
and you're trying to figure out can you
compete like there's no way for us to do
anything
remotely that crazy and obviously it's
not going to be that scale but also it's
like always the question of you know i
always remember
gold and i pistols only like one hit
kills and stupid stuff like that that
were always fun to do where you could
swat yes yeah um what is it gun game
something where they could do
oh yay any of those types of things
would give a lot of freshness to
crucible because those are ones you
won't take as seriously
but you can definitely have some fun get
into them like i mean you can definitely
be good at gun game and you can get
competitive in there
but it's not as you said it's just not
the 14th version of clash
clash control to shooting people it's
like we don't really have much when it
comes to objectives
and that's one of the hardest things
objective modes and it'd be really cool
to see
any of that type of stuff but yeah it's
like sidearms only
and everybody gets the same single shot
sidearm but if you could pick this
like that was what always bugged me i
guess about private matches they weren't
custom games
i think i said that probably on the
podcast forever again yeah good point
private matches should have been custom
games because then you have people
making all of the okay so everybody has
you know void subclasses only well what
class are you picking well i don't know
i can go invisible or i can throw nova
bombs but i make bubbles
so like you could just the certain
things that you could limit with custom
games if they gave us that option
would give so much life to it if i just
wanted to go goof around and be like
all right what crazy stuff is the
community made they just
they bring the private matches is so
limited and i
i always wish for something like but
yeah when you said i don't care about
maps and game modes yeah you could do
all the game modes you ever wanted with
the maps you have right now
so i i agree i think modes mostly
i mean okay some some maps need to be
made around the mode
especially if it's capture the flag or
rift or something like that that's fair
longer maps and less
yeah but yeah definitely more variety
and game modes i think would go far
because you get three more maps
in control who cares you get two new
game modes with the maps we have
i feel there would be more variety there
maps yes take them all did
all day but i think modes i agree would
be
longer at least in legs
i think it's really important because
like casual like
you it's it it has the power to change
the way
current maps play in the game plays in
so many ways like on a casual level like
like or uh party game mode i don't want
to say casual on a party game mode
uh like level and just like for fun
that's just an entirely
fun different way to play the game
that's like like makes it like
it's fun and awesome and hilarious or
silly
and then in the competitive aspect it's
like i remember
one thing that sticks out of me is like
in halo 3 the pit which is a very uh
very uh pretty well renowned map if
you're familiar with halo
like slayer and capture the flag played
so
vastly different on that map where in
capture the flag
you wanted to control a completely
different side of the map
than you did in slayer simply because of
where the spawns were weighted
and like the way the spawn system works
and that's just an example of like just
one map playing like polar opposite
different
like just with a flip of game modes and
that has the power again to refresh your
map like
you know capture the flag is a tougher
one i think because like you said like
the maps in destiny are typically
um some most asymmetrical but even the
symmetrical ones like we think
javelin isn't exactly completely
symmetrical
and on top of that it's like more uh
this like round kind of like
uh it's it's it's not like again like
my example of the pit and halo where
it's like completely symmetrical three
lane type thing
it's like a rounder so that's why i
think the suggestion of something like
oddball
where you you know you have a player
moving objective
would play very well or maybe even like
a hardpoint
or or you know we can go back to salvage
and rift with
appropriate scoring uh could be pretty
cool maybe salvage more applicable to
this example but yeah
my point really is just like game modes
i assume
take less to develop and i think would
refresh the game and the maps we
currently have in many ways
it's one of that transformation in
reference to like what we like we talked
about
this whole long season you know what to
get out of it what
what are you hoping for you know to kind
of keep
you engaged you know during this whole
thing
hmm really for me i think what i'm
hoping for
i was asking chad my bad drew i was
asking chapter
my short answer is the sandbox changes
okay stand by okay fair enough fair
enough
there you go that is simple too uh yeah
i think i think for me my
what i'm expecting and what i hope for
are very different first i'll touch on
the
maps versus game modes thing i 100 agree
that game modes are more important than
maps i think
crucible needs both frankly and if
you're going to introduce more maps
or more game modes then you probably
need maps to go with those
uh in in some cases probably in most
cases depending on how creative you want
to get if it's part of game modes
i think the reason that they have been
receding
in their game modes uh in destiny is
because
their player base is becoming more and
more spread out and i think
cross play is actually going to be an
opportunity for them to say okay now we
can try things again because
you're only managing two separate player
bases pc is always going to be really
strong
and console now is just one unit and so
i think this gives them some freedom to
not worry so much about splitting their
player base which is something that
they've worried about a lot
in recent years whether it's destiny
content vault or
controlling the playlists i have no idea
why scorch canon
game mode is in the game like it makes
no sense i get it because it's a
playlist but like it's like the last
thing that you need
in the crucible at its current state so
i i really hope that they try new things
i hope that they give rift another
shot i hope that they uh try new game
modes
uh i would love it if they'd put like a
big team battle and actually give like
vehicles another shot in
destiny which was something that they
originally tried and then almost
immediately gave up on which is
you know kind of the story of destiny's
pvp than giving up on ideas uh as soon
as they don't work out right away
um and uh but yeah i think that that
would be great i think now is the time
to do it
but i do think that it's not gonna
happen this season uh i think they've
probably got bigger fish to fry
i think they're behind on their release
schedule already that's why witch queen
got delayed
and if it is something they're planning
on doing it probably won't come to witch
queen and this will be season of the
cross play them figuring out how to do
cross playing cross chat and also season
of
halo infinite right like it'll just be
me playing probably other games for a
lot of it
um and i don't say that as a bad thing
i'm a guy who's always said like
sometimes you need uh breaks from
destiny and i
i like i like having some seasons that
are lighter because i don't like to feel
like
this is my second job and i've got my
third job in my case
and i've got to commit to playing
destiny all the time
every single day just to keep up so what
i think will probably happen
is this new season will feel really
light at the beginning and they'll
probably just do that you know 12-week
story or eight-week story or whatever it
is that they normally do
and once that's over the stuff that they
held back
will get released slowly so if there's
like a no man's tail type event that
happens
it won't happen at the usual like three
or four week slot that it normally does
they'll delay it and it'll be sort of
like
whisper the worm where it was at the
tail end of a season and we weren't
really expecting it and it kind of
reignited this interest and destiny i
think that they'll do something like
that
to drive momentum going into which queen
and so i think that
you'll get what seems to be a lighter
season but it'll actually just be the
they'll backload some of the stuff that
they saved and they'll do the story
earlier and it'll feel like the season's
over and then you'll get it
you'll get you know more as you go i
think it'll probably be something like
that but i am expecting it to be lighter
i think that fans probably rightfully so
by this point have an expectation that
it's going to be lighter
because it's the the season right before
a major
expansion and i'm okay with that there's
going to be so much to play
in the meantime and um you're right cog
that
the spring is going to be pretty loaded
with uh
you know games that that that are
going to be like big aaa but they're
also not games that really compete with
destiny they're sure
they're a single player games they're
they're they're offline
that
[Music]
yeah for content creators
but it's for for players there's a lot
to do when your friends aren't online
and then when your friends do get online
you can log into destiny and play so i
don't i don't know that they compete a
lot
the fall has sort of become the window
for
triple a multiplayer games and spring is
sort of
is the story uh single player game so uh
i i think it works out that that destiny
happens to be launching during uh that
window so
um yeah i i'm not expecting a ton for
them to win me over
i i think um i probably agree with
drewski that like a sandbox thing is the
best thing that they could do
because the sandbox changes the pvp
community has
always uh selflessly and thanklessly
carried uh destiny on its back through
the hardest droughts right
and i think that if there's a time to do
it again it's now when they probably
need us to do that
so if they could if they could shake up
the pvp sandbox enough to make it
interesting
and fix some of the stuff that they have
told us they're going to fix especially
if they could do
a patch for cheating or figure out a way
to handle cheating during this
time um i think it has potential to
really be a really good period of like
quality of life improvements anti-cheat
uh
getting new game modes possibly in queue
since they're consolidating their player
base finally
um you know destroying voice chat uh
and making my audio quality uh nightmare
uh all the things that we're looking
forward to in destiny over the next six
months i
i hope uh i hope come to fruition even
if the content isn't there
random question for everyone oh
do we think guided games actually gets
improved with crossfit oh man
yeah i forgot that was even a thing you
forgot it was gonna
yeah before you fix guided games you've
got to fix the new player experience hey
we get an influx man maybe maybe the
sherpas will get profit with these raids
[Laughter]
they could do during the season is they
could do more destiny content vault
stuff they could bring back an old raid
during this period they could
oh bring back an old planet as a patrol
zone there's a lot of potential for them
to do that during this period since
they're light on content i mean what
what would you guys like to see in that
if you if i give it to e what e what a c
i don't expect if they ever bring back
king's fall because that's one obviously
that's high
i expect that next year i don't expect
it right now
i don't expect them just to start
loading up legends with old raids
in seasons is like a thing that they do
i'd
because that obviously was a big selling
point for the season
vault of glass is a big deal there was a
tease that was coming everybody's been
waiting when's it coming when's it
coming when's it coming we knew when it
was coming but
um i mean next season some people are
thinking you know you've got dreaming
city
is there going to be anything that
happens you know the story implications
also wonder
you know shattered throne are we ever
going to finish the time loop is marasav
going to come back i'm curious to see
what happens in the story more than
anything
i mean sandbox keeps things fresh
believe me it's like
but so many things that i do want at
this point are with witch queen that
i'm not that concerned as to season 15
once or anything like that so which
queen is the bigger one for me
bad enough fair enough it's gonna be
interesting man
i i can't wait to see how they just
curious to see how they handle it that's
all this is a unique
time for destiny big you know the big
expansion delay
longer season all these different
factors as far as sandbox and
you know cross play and you know how
they handle and
i just don't want a thousand iron bears
season of the events and season of the
banana yeah it's like you
are gonna have festival you're gonna
have dawning those are gonna be
three weeks and a month probably but i
mean you're gonna see
what what if what if the season was
return of the iron
instead of rise of iron and it was just
one
long iron banner event and
[Music]
oh that'll make people mad oh my lord
no i was like it's i just can't wait for
the 24th
because i did want to actually ask you
guys this because i was talking to chat
a little bit as this will kind of be
something to wrap up
time wise so we can let get drew
probably get some respect jewish time
with the 24th do you guys think we're
gonna get
any preview of season 15 before that or
is it just gonna be
one big like info bomb
do you think they're holding it all
together so it's just like
this is everything or do you think
they'll do like the tuesday trailer or
wednesday trailer webpage
update and then the 24th when servers go
down and they do that
is that just which queen do you think
they're consolidated do you think
i i think season 15 has a lot it's a
prelude to the witch queen and i think
that they
give us most of what we need to know
about witch queen and be hyped
on the the 24th or whatever that event
is
and then we go into season 15 feeling
like we're
playing you know part one of the witch
queen expansion i think that's probably
what
but you know it'll be more like season
of arrivals where we're not really
getting a whole lot but it's sort of
like oh stuff's
falling in line you know we're getting
closer and closer but it's the
it yeah that that's my guess so you
think everything comes on the 24th
which queen yeah i think we
we learn about what's going on and what
it's going to be about and we get our
you know cade's going to get killed uh
sort of reveal
on that day uh and then and then it's
all just kind of like teasing and
and uh prepping for that uh in season
15.
that'd be my guess what you think man
i don't know um it's tough to say i i
i'm kind of
leaning on the edge of like i think it
might just be an info bomb
i'm not sure though i'm really uncertain
yeah i'm in the same boat i don't know i
don't know
this is unique territories yeah yeah not
i don't know what to expect this is you
know i wasn't really expecting this to
be honest
you know i was just like oh you know we
get the new season and
that's it and it's like oh no we're
gonna talk about this witch queen i'm
like oh okay we got logos and
like what's this about so yeah i mean
i yeah i'm really confused on how
they're gonna handle you know what
because if you promote witch queen
hard this far ahead
kind of different strategy you know what
i'm saying
i don't know i don't know this again i
i'm very curious to see
what this is where this is going you
know what about you you like wait
what are you thinking how they what what
the approach is going to be
i think i mean i don't know if we've
said it i know travis you kind of hinted
at it i think
whatever happens in season 15 as you
said travis
is this prologue of witch queen it is
the building point
it is really setting finally lining up
the dominoes may it be whatever happens
in the season
i think has enough of a tie to witch
queen
that they don't want to preview
season 15 saying hey this is the story
this is the villain you're going to
fight these are the things that you're
going to do
and then a week later go here's the
trailer for witch queen
because we might have already like dug
in and figured half that stuff out
because i mean we had the web page for
season of what is this season
splicer we had the web page for spicer
but we knew expunge was the thing
if you go the definition of expunges to
like remove something or like okay what
are we getting rid of like
then so again if we have those little
tidbits
everybody goes crazy deep on every word
that bungie puts out there
so if they have like half a week or a
week to dig into all this like trailer
and
frames and web page and what are the
missions called and all these other
things
you get all this information before that
witch queen preview happens
either they do that and witch queen is
so big that didn't even matter
or they just do it all at once because
they know the one store is so connected
to the other they can't talk about them
separately
my guess i i would like to see just you
know
shut down the servers for like three or
four hours tuesday morning
like you know for me it'd be like eight
o'clock to noon so they shut everything
down
and then you know at like nine or ten my
time so a couple hours back whenever
they just schedule uh you know
vlog or whatever they're gonna do or
vidoc sorry that's their term uh
schedule one of those and it's gonna be
you know 30 40 minutes of them
sitting there having chats talking about
what's coming saying what's next
explaining kind of
this is i think what's going to kick off
the final trilogy and i think this is
going to be the big like
40 like a big vidoc i think this has got
to be it
that's my guess because at this point i
didn't expect this moment to happen at
all
i was saying hey there was going to be a
witch queen trailer at the game awards
when they finally feel comfortable
without like a date because the game
awards are in december because of the
delay
yeah yeah so now that we've got the
giant queen logo in august i'm going
they gotta give us a pretty good amount
of information now i think or at least
start
you know saying what's to come and yeah
there's some history here i mean destiny
2
got a big summer event that was hosted
by
bungie specifically to reveal that
and that was a in advance b in this time
slot
and c sort of like building hype
way early i think uh is is uh kind of
their strategy here
but um yeah my
my i i just don't see how they how they
unlink the two
right and you you can't just you can't
have uh
this giant info dump for witch queen and
go okay now go hang out with lord
saladin and and return of iron season
and and have him uh he does all the
dialogue for all the strikes on the
vanguard strike playlist
um you know they can't just have
something like that so i i would guess
that they've got to go big on this thing
uh and and have you build up hype in the
season just like they did
for season arrivals and this is their
destiny three i mean
beyond light was the 3.0 version of
destiny but they sort of retconned that
and said okay
now we're adding an extra year to
destiny so this is effectively
uh their 3.0 i think what we'll see on
the 24th
is what the bungie employees saw a few
months ago and we're tweeting about
yeah i think we'll see yeah when they
would get yelling bungie and capital
letters
they were yelling bungie and saying i'm
super stoked i think
we'll see whatever they saw on the 24th
that's my guess and it'll just make us
super hyped we'll want to play season 15
even if it doesn't have a lot to it
just because you know we're we're living
yeah we'll be happy
we'll be off the euphoria of it yeah i
see what you're saying
does the story like are you one much for
like the story and the hype and
everything or is crucible keep you
pretty contained drew
it's funny because like crucible keeps
me like
you know and and bill or making builds
and sandbox stuff
is like definitely what holds my
attention but i
really try to get into the story because
it looks good and i
i like my my chat always tries to like
inform because i'm like guys
i'm like trying to pay attention and
like i'm really not good at following
things so i'm like i need
like explanations but so i don't know
tldr like i i give like a real honest
effort and i'm genuinely interested
but i'm really bad at following and it's
like i feel like i'm too lost in the
sauce at this point
like i i tried
i like that i liked it
hey um yeah story is gonna be
big for me you know to see where they go
with it you know they're clearly trying
to set stuff up and
we're seeing leaks already of things and
conclusions just things
so we we we got i'm very curious you
know i want to know how high the stakes
are going to be
and um i can't wait man i i that
that to me how they set up
witchcreen is very critical for me i i
think
this is a you know i'm not going to say
do or die for them because you know look
we're going to be playing this game
regardless
because if we've been here long enough
but if they want that true
[Music]
taken king shot in the arm they got to
do something
they got to get us to go whoa okay they
not only
because i think the thing about taking
king that people forget is just that not
only
narratively it was so cool they also
sandbox changed we we got to you know
the sub classes
and and stuff like that it was so
massive and i know we're not getting a
forsaken level i know
but man like it would be a good
opportunity for them to really do some
changes that people go damn it that's
what i'm talking about
now i'm interested i'm day one pre-order
like you know
it's got to be a combination of the
narrative the sandbox everything and
get everybody riled up and then you know
if they do that then it's not going to
matter i think i don't know if travis
said it or ajewski said it
it's not going to matter if this the was
it season 15 is this one coming up
if that's weak because the euphoria is
so high everybody's gonna be like oh my
god they
killed like how they kill kate or
whatever you know saying like we gotta
sabotage gotta get it you know what's
the hell whatever's going on and
just build it up kind of thing and you
know maybe
to ease dismay they may have to do
something
uh narratively revealed in a trailer to
get people emotional i know
the marketing machine what's the worst
but man don't kill off kade in a friggin
trailer
sorry i think we will get something like
that
we'll get like the osiris oh suspicious
betrayal or something like that there
will be like some sort of linchpin
because to drewski's point there is a
whole player base that are
just like drewski and i would argue that
they're in the majority who
really do not care about story unless
it's a headline like
kade is dead right then even the
drewskis are like what kid's dead
right so i think they have to do
something like that if they want to have
universal hype but i don't know if they
will i mean it's not it's not activision
they don't have
they don't have investors anymore right
it's not the same but we'll see
he's like david if y'all don't stop
spoiling stuff and let it be discovered
in game damn it i can't stand the
marketing
that's just because he can't make a
video about it he's got sad affleck
right now and i feel it
i feel the sad afflict right now because
they like no one's listening to him and
he's like
damn it like give me one moment when you
don't damn spoiler in the chat i feel
him i feel like he needs one where we go
oh we see that coming
right yeah you know you can have
multiple twists in a story right one and
still have three in your back pocket but
yeah
the problem with with destiny is that
it's storytelling is like
you get one twist every four years if
that and that's pretty much there yeah
just don't do that in a trailer
no i mean i i think we can definitely
like
kind of we all have our hopes but i i do
see the eyes looking much farther out to
the witch queen horizon
but the 24th will be big like the 24th
is the day that everybody who's part of
this community
makes content plays a decent amount kind
of is curious what goes on
going on if they don't know about the
stream and watch it that day it's going
to be on
every website be like this is what's
coming so
that is whether it's the lead up till
then or the 24th is a giant info
explosion
it's gonna be it's gonna be a big one so
i mean that's
it's a lot to look forward to and it may
be six months away after that but
i still think that's that's gonna be an
exciting day and then which queen
obviously sleep
we say there's a lot of weight on it a
lot but i think there is i think there
has to be for
kicking off the final trilogy as this
was like really the 2.9 of destiny 3
and then now we're finally gonna get our
final trilogy
yeah well that is about probably a good
place to call it i think
drew's gotta get some sleeps before he
passes out on us we're like
drew drew wait i'm just kidding no
you've been awesome man thank you uh
thank you brother
but yeah final thing is definitely to
give you the time to tell
everybody where to find you where they
can find you in concert you know what's
going on what you got going on
um it's the floor is yours so anybody
who hears this can come find you
find you in your twitch chat whatever
you got going on so sir what do you got
going coming all that stuff yeah uh you
can mainly find me
on twitch twitch.tv slash drewskis
and then uh youtube.comchannel and
occasionally on twitter uh
drewski's channel at drewski's channel
although
um i'm mainly again on twitch
oh hello man again thank you for coming
by
love what you do love the insight you
know i'm definitely glad you mentioned
for our fire range which we didn't shout
out which are really
i mean justin bro
like i just love it just the in-depth
sandbox knowledge like i
like literally if the 12 was a sandbox
every
week i'd be like that i literally
gush and geek out so when i see you fall
out
cool guy burke you know what i'm saying
like i can't i i love that stuff like i
i love the minutia of the sandbox and
how you
even with your videos you break down oh
great video on the uh the shotgun the
aggressive changes
you know i really i really yeah dude you
killed it with that just to show
like to me anything that changes the
game fundamentally in the crucible
and you're dead you guys dedication to
the crucible because damn it me and
travis we
we need that that gives us life man when
we see people that care about what we
have
that's all we got man hey you guys are
like
connoisseurs with that stuff and yeah
salute to that podcast
love everyone on it and salute to you
like i said for coming through and i i
love my pvp guys
that bring the knowledge so thank you
for coming by the campfire sir
yeah you're uh you guys are more than
welcome it was a lot of fun it was fun
to talk about
um a bunch of different stuff a lot of
the things that
i you know i guess didn't expect to
expect to talk about even that that i
really enjoyed um like uh
so thank you thank you for listening to
me and having me here
and talking about myself um
and and sharing you know some
speculation and what's to come in
destiny and uh
i appreciate it thanks for acknowledging
the things you did and
you know uh it yeah i i i just really
appreciate it so thank you guys
oh it's our pleasure absolutely hello
well as we wrap up um
thank you of course but we'll let these
two get out of here first
travis what do you got coming anything
you got on the
on deck that you can talk about yours is
always secretive nda in disclosure
snipers
[Laughter]
uh but yeah you can read my reviews and
articles on ign.com you can follow me on
twitter at thai guy travis and you can
find me
on this podcast uh the the last word or
on a podcast bitcast that i do on
saturday mornings
that you can find on my twitter yeah
that's that's a new one so i'm doing
these
sunday mornings uh apparently that's
gonna get my podcast
i'm just doing glad to be just doing one
podcast up in here and
i got these guys doing like two three
gotta gotta broaden my horizons
you need those you need those hateful
takes that's really what they're out
here for you gotta
you gotta just say something real mean
and out there and i'm just kidding uh
no uh but but thank you guys for having
me on the show as always i've always
been loved
and uh i'm i'm glad i get to talk about
destiny every week again
no doubt we found a home for you by the
campfires
exactly exactly bring them in bring them
in yeah there's a little stray cat and
you invited me
there's a there's an entire game coming
out about that by the way do you guys
see that
strange it's a game called annapurna did
their thing and it's
uh oh yeah yeah that's that was
announced it's like a whole stray cat
you're gonna have this little like baby
backpack you have this little bot
that'll communicate with people but
you're a cat
some people who love cats are gonna like
just dive into this game it's crazy so
it's
it's coming i forget when but yeah
that's it's a thing
what about you cog what do you got
coming up any iron lords podcast guests
minutes all of your things yeah man got
some stuff going on
that the duke shout out to the dukes out
of defining duke oh my boy maddie
we just recorded a couple episodes
they're up on did the ultimate and we
did a regular one to find duke and
they're up on the patreon now but
the regular defined it will be live
publicly for the free
on sunday as well early so you get that
it's a pretty good episode on
saturday we will revisit the sega
podcast that
unceremoniously crashed due to my
technical issues
so we got that back revisited revisited
yeah yeah remastered there you go
he hit the soul as a second kid your
joke hit the soul cause i was like
why would sage everything got to go
wrong
[Music]
that podcast went the way of the sega
saturn i guess
facts yes yes it was it was over quickly
and then it's going to last about as
long as the dreamcast anyways continue
[Laughter]
anyway but yeah other than that
obviously this sunday online podcast we
will have my man
dustin dustin can fly from last stand
media
so he will be in the realm we're gonna
talk some news we're gonna talk some
playstation we talk some
a lot of stuff going on in gaming so
come check that out
sunday 1pm eastern ireland podcast
youtube channel
and uh yeah that's pretty much it that
did that this weekend and um of course
that last word podcast a thai guy and a
a cheetah and a ninja get together and
talk about this game
that we like so appreciate everybody
coming through especially
the fake lord cognito that had to show
his love his undying love and support
you know absolutely there's gonna make
one of you running around there salute
to the bernie account still
he was an incognito incognito
salute again absolutely for pulling up
man it was really
really cool but e which got going on sir
uh i got a vacation next week so i will
not be here so if you guys are looking
for the last word it probably will be
off next week unless just like
there's something crazy yeah if they
give you guys like a 20-page sandbox
thing these two are definitely going to
talk about it if they want to release
the witch queen thing early
yeah like they'll have to uh and then
but next the week after on the 13th i
will be like
traveling home but you guys already know
what happened on epilogue so they might
be talking about that one
yeah of course i'll be here on the 20th
that one will do the 20th will be
we'll answer some of the questions if
the 20th is either going to be very
quiet
if we don't have anything yet we're like
okay we have nothing guys what do what
what are we talking about and then
everything happens on the 24th but yeah
i got vacation uh a couple indie games
just like coming up i played the demo
for grime on steam which was fun played
that for about an hour
kind of a 2d side-scrolling you know
little souls elements to it little
decent combat and dodging
um some of those like souls indies that
look a lot of fun every so often
you need to play death's door it's it's
you oh
i know that one's definitely my list so
you it is i know
you know yeah that one i gotta play it's
definitely on the list and
yeah so it's just in between this time
of like what you know
between seeing what's up with the world
of destiny on kind of a weekly basis
playing some other stuff in between
working through mass effect 2
as well and then yeah epilogue when i
get back from a vacation
hopefully i come back to something cool
nice uh
let me try to hold it down yep you guys
will hold it down but yeah drew thank
you very much for showing up appreciate
it
glad to get to know you more glad to get
a little insight into how you got here
and of course your scientific
cone knowledge takes of everything in
the world of destiny is
always great keep doing what you're
doing fire team chat keep those guys in
shape make sure and you know
tell fellow to run a tight ship over
there you know
keep them keep them in check keep them
in check but no like everything you're
doing is
always awesome even like i just
literally checked you this morning when
you were streaming your
halo bit that you were doing and just
working that drill i'm like he does just
you just click heads just if you run
into drewski and crucible just leave the
game find another one
it's probably not gonna go well for you
so um but thank you for your time this
morning
i know we were a little shaky getting in
here but glad we got you on glad
everything worked out
for sure yeah but yeah like i said guys
thanks for having me and uh
thanks i i appreciate it a lot and thank
you for the acknowledgement
uh it means a lot absolutely um well for
this episode thank you guys
uh it's been a little long this morning
but we will wrap it up episode number
160
july 30th by the time you guys see me
it's gonna be the middle of august again
so have a good one guys thank you very
much and for this episode
it has been the last word